[Music]
hey you guys
what's that girl's name again from this
summer florence view yeah
jenny's worried that florence p was
going to see that video and think that
she's got a big head well because sandra
sandra changed her name to has a big
head well see that's the thing i think
dudes when they try to compliment people
like that i think they're not really
i mean girls are gonna focus on the has
a big head part and he's like but it's
cute though and i'm just kind of like
yeah but always i'm
like is my head big well what it is i
didn't well because
i will tell you one thing i didn't
realize that i had flat feet
until you told me that i had flat feet i
should have known that when you were
buying shoes
i just thought i had regular ass feet
like everybody i never thought about it
yeah and then you were like man you got
like some flat feet and i was like are
they
yeah and now i'm like all self-conscious
about it yeah
well in the army you know dudes to keep
track of who's flat-footed and who isn't
because you know what i mean it has to
do with boots
and [ __ ] marching yeah in the ifter
so yeah you knew who flat-footed dudes
are
i probably should have should have known
there's certain advantages to it
although it's it's probably not good
because i was looking up because i've
had like lately like the last
probably year year or maybe two yeah
i've had like really really bad
um heel pain in my left foot and then
like
pain in my like big toe joint my friend
i think it might be a plantar
what is it called plantar fasciitis or
whatever it is
um which usually comes from well it
comes from a lot of things but it comes
from like not
you know having ill-fitting shoes
wearing high-heeled shoes being on your
shoe
on your feet too much um that kind of
[ __ ]
so i suspect that i might be having that
problem well you're kind of like a
free-range child you know i mean
i don't think your mom really [ __ ]
you know knew what to do with your kids
i don't really know but you know [ __ ]
if we had kids that had flat feet
especially when they were little kids or
special shoes you were supposed to get
them
well now i my feet when i was a kid
because i remember
vaguely yeah that when i was in fifth or
sixth grade i remember there was some
talk not so much because there were flat
people because my feet were like i was a
little bit pigeon
toed yeah not anymore and um so i think
that there was some kind of talk of like
me like wearing braces or like wearing
feet like that i think
i think i remember that because i
remember thinking to myself when i was
in elementary school oh god please like
don't make me wear those because
everybody will
like already makes fun of me as it is
and it's like that it'll be even worse
but it's like i never did end up wearing
them so arched feet
are mostly kind of a european thing i
think a lot of asians have arched feet
but flat feet isn't typically an african
type foot
it's better at running but it's not good
in cold weather
the whole the whole reason for arch feet
was to if because
people in cold weather climates had
evolved to get as much of their foot off
the ground as possible
that makes sense because it sucks a lot
of heat yeah out of the bottom of your
body
you know through the feet because cold
ground just sucks it right out of you
yeah
civilians don't [ __ ] know they're
mostly indoors and temperature
controlled and [ __ ]
if you're in sub-zero weather it makes a
huge [ __ ] difference in whether or
not you're [ __ ] flat-footed or not
you're trying to get as much of your
down body off of that [ __ ] cold
surface as you can even if you had
even if you had some kind of primitive
leather shoe it would make a big
difference
but really flat feet are the best for
running
they like all your real good runners
especially when it comes to speed
they're flat-footed
honestly though like now well first
remember for a while like i was getting
those uh
inserts that you put in your shoes like
to give you like arches
yeah uh because my feet were starting to
hurt and it's like it's just gotten
worse and worse and worse and like i you
know i walk a lot like
because i walk like miles and miles
every day and it's getting to a point
now where i'm just kind of like man i
really gotta do something about this
because it's like i'm not gonna be able
to walk
you need to get you some some arch
supports yeah something like that yeah
typically caucasians aren't genetically
really supposed to have them
and they tell you too i was like looking
it up on like webmd and [ __ ] like that
and they said there's not really a
[ __ ] ton they can do about it they said
you know it's like if it gets really bad
they can like inject steroids and stuff
but like to get rid of the pain but
they're like the best thing to do
is um like foot massage like get kind of
those foam balls and like
roll them under your feet all the time
like to kind of because it's supposed to
like loosen up your foot muscles because
that's kind of what the problem putting
an arch support in there of course
pushes the foot up into a into a better
posture
you know what i mean it's because a lot
a lot of white people that have flat
feet
it was more like a collapsed arch than
it was
that they were genetically born with
flat feet they weren't
born that way they collected the arches
collapsed
through not wearing shoes or weight or
you know
being being heavy as a child can do it
there's a lot of things that can do it
that's what i mean i don't really
remember if i had flat feet as a kid and
then there was just like fallen arches
later if my feet have always been like
this i don't really remember
i mean i don't know they were just my
feet i didn't really think about it
so it's possible that i could have had
fallen arches later just because i wore
like shitty shoes yeah
you know what i'm saying but you know i
don't know because i wasn't heavy as a
kid
i was like i was actually pretty skinny
i'm i look at people like there's
sides of beef anyway i'm not sure if
that's a good thing
no it comes from it comes from being in
the horse industry and
comes from being in basically physical
sports
you know what i mean [ __ ] military
background and stuff you're looking at
somebody said what
can you do with them what what you
shouldn't do with this person because we
just see each other can we eat this
person yeah will they be delicious
people are pack animals to us that's
nice people are packing it's always nice
to be considered in that way
well you know i had to carry my own body
weight
and equipment you know about 140 550
pounds
when i was young mr rabata says jenny
you're pretty skinny now well thank you
i'm not but
thank you
[Laughter]
see what everybody's doing but yeah so i
don't know i've just been thinking about
it lately it's like it was
when i before i went on my walk this
morning because i'm still going god damn
it
um because i got to see mr mcguire i got
to give him his food
every day and uh but so this morning
like i did like a whole bunch of like
more calf stretches than i would
normally do and that helped
like through half of it but then on the
way back it was worse
so i'm just kind of like hmm i'm not
really sure
i don't know i have to do something
about it the toe the the joint on the
big toe isn't too bad because it's like
i'm not
right stepping right on it but like the
left foot it's almost kind of like
it's almost kind of like there's no skin
on the heel it's like i'm stepping on
like bone
you know i mean that's what it feels
like yeah there's no pad there
yeah and it feels like really really bad
like i looked it up and i'm imagining
that's probably what it is and like i
said they said there's not really
all that much they can do about it she
has some steroids in there other than
injection steroids instead of getting
in horrible cases they say which one no
but they said in horrible cases you
might could get surgery but
it's like i can't afford that one and
it's like two i'm not going through all
that [ __ ]
just better shoes shooting yeah that's
what i'm saying so i'm gonna like
kind of get and maybe get some of those
foot like roller foot massage things
because they said that actually does
help like rolling your feet like over
those
uh you know like foam balls and [ __ ] i
said foam balls
that's funny terry says flat feet people
have a lot of arch enemies
yeah yeah such a dad joke
[Laughter]
okay so is my head big no i don't have a
big head right
see i never thought about it her head
isn't
big it just looks big
it looks big i'm sorry florence yeah
you're beautiful
yeah she's cute i like her she's
exciting too i think she's awesome
her head isn't big it's it's that she's
she's small
and she's got kind of a slender frame
and
i whenever when you put hair on her head
or and she's got a real strong
jaw and kind of a square face yeah
so when she has short hair or any kind
of hat on or anything she's
she looks like a lollipop she's got a
big cute head and a little body
but it's cute it's like something you
know it's like like a gray
like a gray alien she looks little bitty
like sure
she looks short i mean she looks short i
don't know how short she is but she
looks short
yeah like not that there's anything
wrong with that i'm short too her best
movie is fighting with my family i
thought we saw that twice in the theater
and
she's so cute in that yeah she's so cute
and i own it on blu-ray it's it's a
really good movie
it's that was i wasn't expecting like i
saw it and like i saw some of the people
that were in it like you know the dude
that
like was one of the writers of the
office and stuff and so i figured oh
that'll probably
be good but it was like way better than
i was expecting it
and it's also like a great florida movie
it's shot in locations that me and jenny
know
we know those places yeah a lot of it
was shot here in orlando right here i
mean it's a british movie so
you know yeah and you know when she was
getting into wrestling
and uh just her family story you know
paige you know it's about paige
yeah and um it's kind of like
a little bit more upbeat beat version of
pain and gain which that's another
really good florida movie but that's
yeah no one gets shot and killed yeah no
one gets shot at this one but which
yeah or beaten to death or whatever so
but fight with my family about paige
english girl being a wrestler and pain
again
broadhead muscle instructor who [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh uh uh besides her ransom
rants and he rants as a jewish new york
dude for [ __ ] money
and he ends up getting a life sentence
because that dude died
that's another [ __ ] fact that's just
ensues and yeah yeah and that it's
another fantastic it's a dark comedy
though though though though though
though
it's got the rock in it and everything
[ __ ] it's got little [ __ ] marky
mark what's his name [ __ ] what's his
real name what marky mark's right
mark mark wahlberg and he does a great
job in the movie of just playing a
dumbass
he plays he's really good at those types
of roles i don't think he's a dumb ass
person in real life i don't know he's
not but um he's really good at playing
those types of
well because we were talking about that
when we were talking about boogie nights
he's just really good at playing these
sort of like
wide-eyed naive yeah like kind of
dummies but
that are kind of endearing at the same
time he plays this muscle head
who's got this gym down south florida he
owns a gym doesn't he or does he just
work there i don't remember
i think he just i think he just works
this works there he he's a physical
instructor
and he just says this the [ __ ] is
stupidest [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
funny as
[ __ ] and he decides he thinks he's a lot
smarter than he really is
and he makes a lot of money problem
around the world i've noticed
yeah he gets involved in all kinds of
[ __ ] crooked [ __ ]
and uh he and drugs and stuff and
[ __ ] he ends up making a [ __ ] ton of
money down in south florida
chasing [ __ ] good looking women and
[ __ ] he just loses all of his [ __ ]
money just
it's and [ __ ] ends up committing all
these crimes and he just goes down in
flames
taking everybody with him takes his
buddy down with him another muscle head
played by the rock
and that's that was the rock's [ __ ]
greatest role of all time was to play
mark wahlberg's [ __ ] brother or a
buddy down here in south florida
he plays a [ __ ] [ __ ]
musclehead jesus freak yeah it's [ __ ]
great man
which is basically all based on real
people i think the rocks character is
kind of like a combination of a couple
different characters
but yeah they're all kind of like
because we did a review we did a review
on that movie did you because somebody
said it to us yeah yeah he was a real
uh real hardcore christian but he's
doing all this these crimes and
you just got to see it man it's a great
movie great somebody brought up uh
speaking of mark wahlberg somebody
brought up fear
that is actually a good movie and he
plays a bad guy in that because does he
play like a stalker i kind of feel like
that's
yeah like a stalker boyfriend type
situation i remember that being really
it's like a thriller but for you
i remember him being you people who
don't live in florida
and you want to get that florida vibe
those are the two movies that you want
to get
you want to get paying a game and fight
with my family
even though like i said a lot of
fighting with my family is at the uk
yeah some of that's in the uk
but that's be that would be that's a
good movie if if you lived in europe
what it would be like to move to florida
there's some
a lot of that in it it's like especially
if you were to it was just funny like
the first time we watched it and i was
just kind of like hey
i know where that is that's on the
street
[Laughter]
yeah i guess everybody thinks that
whenever their hometown is in the movie
it's just like kind of funny like to see
yeah they're passing all the damn
buildings we pass we go to the club yeah
it's funny because um speaking of
europeans come to the u.s i found this
show last night so last night
since i didn't really need to watch a
movie for this for
uh you know the movies retrospective or
matinees or anything
i was just kind of like okay well i'm
going to finish up because remember i
said i was watching that series it's on
amazon prime
um it's about ted bundy but it's called
falling for a killer so it's kind of
mostly from
one is from like his you know
girlfriend's point of view like you know
the
uh her what's her name elizabeth that
was going out with him
at the time when he was doing all the
murders and she didn't like know about
it and she was kind of the one that
she i don't she didn't turn him in but
she kind of like alerted the police
and um so they have an interview with
her and you know
the daughter that ted bundy helped raise
which is [ __ ] up who was grown up now
obviously
um so i finished watching that and that
was really good and then i thought to
myself man
it's like i'm i'm in a gordon ramsay
kind of
mood i'm kind of feeling that kind of
vibe and so i'm looking on tubie
because a lot of they have like all the
gordon ramsay on amazon prime but i
think you have to have like the
discovery plus add-on which we don't
have
so i went on to because they have a
bunch of free [ __ ] and
on to be they had this entrancing
show how does gordon ramsay does he have
like that time
turner [ __ ] from harry potter because
it's like how the [ __ ] does he have time
to do all this but he has a million
[ __ ] shows a million take very long
to shoot i guess not
but it's like so there was this one show
it wasn't like a whole series it was
just like one show but i think it was
like an hour and a half or two hours or
something
so it must have been like some kind of
special and it was like gordon ramsay's
american road trip that's what it was
called right and it was him
and that french dude fred something
that's what i've seen him on some of
other gordon's friendships and a syrian
dude
no well the other dude was italian it
was italian the other dude was geno
something the geno dude that wrote all
the cookbooks and then fred
dude the chef that knows all the [ __ ]
about the wine
i've seen that guy before so it was all
of them and they rented a camper
and they went out they did like a
western
like western united states um road trip
so they went to like la they went to san
francisco
they went to texas they went down to
mexico they went like dinos and it was
[ __ ] hilarious the three of them
i guess that's like their best friends
or whatever and the three of them
were just like [ __ ] it was just like
three idiot teenagers
like doing a road trip they were just
like and the two europeans
well no that's what i'm saying but
that's what was so funny about it it's
like gino specifically the italian was
just like drunk all the time and it was
just like
but he was like not even shy about it
and it was super super funny
and it's just like they were jacked
about seeing cowboys real cowboys yeah
they got like cowboy outfits they got to
like do
they look like cowboys when they got
dressed they got to the ranch they got
to like go
and like they you could she was all
honored to [ __ ] meet real cowboys
and then eat with them well the two like
the french guy was like well the french
guy and the italian guy were like man
and we all wanted to be cowboys when we
were
when we were little boys you know so
it's like they were super yeah because
they
were really into westerns and stuff and
so they were super super jacked about it
and it's just like and another thing is
you couldn't get those two european
dudes you could not
get them to keep their [ __ ] clothes
on seriously they were just like running
around
with their wangs hanging out well there
was a whole thing where
they had a a sequence where they went
there in la
and i guess gordon has a house there
a mansion it's a big huge [ __ ]
mansion compound
situation and his mom was staying there
so they went to visit his mom and then
he decided that they were gonna have
like a burger competition like so
whoever had the best burger right and
then the mom who's
pretty cranky and she's pretty awesome
so she's gonna judge like whose burger
is the best of like all of them so
gordon wants to do like an american
style one
but good and then like the european
dudes were going to do like more
european
and so gordon of course is just like
well the ones that lose you have to take
off all your clothes and jump in the
pool
and so of course the europeans lost
because the mom was judging and this mom
wanted to see him naked
i kind of think she did man about it mr
roboto brings up the uh florida muscle
ninjas remember those
pain and gain that's [ __ ] funny you
guys got to see the movie to understand
that they
those muscle dudes dressed up like
ninjas in the 80s
to [ __ ] threaten people and to abduct
them
and people were they were seen and when
people reported that it was ninjas
the cops didn't believe it but they were
they were they were muscle men dressed
up as digits
so in a way and i think even when we saw
the movie yeah i said that's a really
good idea because if like
people call the cops and say hey i just
got like beat up by ninjas yeah cops are
gonna be like [ __ ] off
the thing is that the dudes were so dumb
that they dressed up like ninjas not
thinking that that would be a great
disguise that the cops wouldn't believe
it they just did that because they
thought you were supposed to dress up
like [ __ ] because they thought they
looked badass yeah
they were really bad ass they got no
checks let's get a spirit halloween
costume what else is going on here but
like i said that was like accidentally
they stumbled into like kind of a good
idea
yeah you know what i'm saying it would
just be like i mean i feel like if i was
i'm not gonna do this but if i was gonna
like
uh you know not rob a bank but because
you probably just get shot
but if you're just gonna like mug people
or whatever it's like wear one of those
big like [ __ ] inflatable
or foam dinosaur suits or whatever and
then people say i just got mugged by a
dinosaur says that the new uh sander who
has a big head
said the new m like shaman ding dog
movie has been out for a few days
haven't watched it yet though
i don't know anything about that i've
been seeing uh mixed reviews
because because i watched a couple
reviews of it like non-spoiler ones
because i said i maybe i'll go see this
one i don't know it looks kind of cool
like from the preview um
some of the channels i watch like that
you know that i respect their opinion
and stuff
were like you know yeah i really dug it
but i could see how other people
could think it was dumb and then the
other channels were like this is the
dumbest movie i ever made
victor garcia says samsung tv has the
kitchen nightmares channel
yeah a whole kitchen nightmare 24 7.
yeah
there's probably like on pluto tv i
would think that they probably have a
kitchen nightmares because pluto tv
if you didn't know pluto.tv has a whole
mystery science theater channel
and they have a whole rifftrax channel
so you can just put it on i mean the mst
one since
you know the episodes are so long they
usually will play like they're four or
five episodes a day and they'll just
like repeat
them a couple of times but the riff
tracks ones i guess the rifftrax does
that too
and the rifftrax is cool because they'll
like put shorts in between and stuff
like if there's
it's pretty cool like i said when i was
on vacation and i was in my airbnb
i just they had pluto tv on the thing so
i just like left it on the mst channel
and just like let it run all the time
like while i was doing other [ __ ]
because i like having that was something
i used to do like back in my old house
like a lot of times i would just like
put mystery science theater even a you
know
episodes i'd seen like a bunch of times
i would just put it on the background
like while i was cleaning or doing
something else
i don't know there's something like
comforting about it
so that's what i kind of did when i was
there too mike says ramsay gets on my
nerves after a while
i i can see that um joe nash says i got
the cookbook today yay
all right yeah y'all should do a show
about the sun gym gang
well we did a review of painted gan the
movie and i think we talked about
the gang on there did we not so it's
kind of like we did a show about it
because we were kind of talking about
what happened in real life
fourth row down what's your emergency or
yeah it's ninjas
there's a tag by ninjas that ninjas beat
me up yeah
see and i can see if if i was a police
dispatcher i'd probably just be like
yeah go [ __ ] yourself
and just like hang up because i'm sure
they get like a bunch of stupid [ __ ]
phone calls
all the time yeah yeah what started the
whole thing is that a dude moved down
from
moved here from from new york which
happens quite a lot we got a lot we know
a lot of people that move here from new
york
he was a real rich guy and he was
one of he was uh the dudes
i don't what was the dude's what's the
dude's name in real life not ma
wahlberg but the guy who mark wahlberg
was playing do you know who it is now i
can't remember
he was he worked at the gym there and he
was his trainer he was training this
dude from new york and the guy was
uppity
and uh bragging a lot about how much
money that he had was because of his
education
so mark target or that guy targeted him
for that because i'm gonna steal all
this money
and abducted him abducted him was
torturing him
over a long period of time tried to get
was it
they're trying to get him to sign over
stuff and he did sign over a bunch of
[ __ ] to him yeah his house and
everything i think
well yeah because they moved into it you
remember yeah he moved into it
and trashed it trashed it [ __ ] it up
and um but the guy [ __ ] ended up
dying
he got charged for murder they
eventually figured out that it was him
but
they were doing weird [ __ ] too and they
were i think weren't they scaring him i
think they scared him a couple times
before
um before they abducted him or did
somebody see that you see him being
abducted and it was ninjas
i think that i think a [ __ ] it was in a
parking lot right right yeah yeah
i think during the day i think a ninja's
attack if i remember correctly
it's been a while it's [ __ ] crazy i
gotta see it again
jason badass says would you guys review
the first two ghostbusters movies with
afterlife coming out soon
we probably should because we did no we
haven't done
we haven't done ghostbusters and
ghostbusters too yeah because afterlife
um i'm not sure when that's coming out
but yeah i just saw that because they've
been talking about like that
that forever and i'm like well you guys
better hurry up because [ __ ] harold
ramus is dead and
it's probably gonna say a lot of the
people say well i don't know it might
not it might not
i just don't don't go into things with
that attitude
the [ __ ] reboot gang game the past
couple [ __ ] years has been [ __ ] well
this is supposed to this is supposed to
be a sequel
like so they're having like all the
surviving people are still gonna be in
it
yeah but like i said harold ramis who
played egon he died
um i think wait don't like everybody's
is dan akron still alive dan akron's
still alive right
bill murray's still alive so okay so two
out of three
i'm just skeptical i mean econ was a
good character though and like they're
so they're gonna have to like write that
into the movie i'd imagine
they came out with the all-female
ghostbusters and it [ __ ] bombed
uh they said it was terrible i didn't
see it i haven't seen it so i can't say
because i've seen some channels that
said you know it's like stop like it was
perfectly fine like i don't know what
everybody was like crying about but you
know what i mean
but i didn't i don't know i i didn't
like i i didn't see it because i was
just kind of like well we didn't really
you know need another like a
ghostbusters remake necessarily
but i don't mind i if they want to do a
sequel as long as it's good i'm not
bothered
um i'm just very skeptical that
anything's going to be victor says
slimer is still alive
yeah so there you go i think the only
thing that's going to be good is the new
dune
the new dune supposedly is [ __ ]
badass
oscar says are you guys excited to see
antlers when the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
coming out because it's like i remember
seeing the trailer for that
way back when the theaters were still
open that was the one like about the
the wendigo [ __ ] and it's like oh and
the trailer like looked really good and
it kept getting pushed back and pushed
back
and it like it looked really good so
yeah i'm jacked about that one i want to
see the new nicholas cage movie hog
pig pig that's right pig my sister saw
it what she said was good yeah she liked
it
okay pig [ __ ] cage is good man he's a
brilliant actor he's a [ __ ] brilliant
actor
well he he gives it uh he gives it 110
110 even if that was a shitty movie even
that [ __ ] shitty
predator [ __ ] ripoff movie that he
did
he was the best part of that movie he
knew he was in a piece of [ __ ]
but he still he was just selling it he
doesn't [ __ ] phone it in
he's gonna [ __ ] go 100 well like i
said that's why i respect the dude
because he's just kind of like i know
this movie is going to suck but i'm just
going to like [ __ ] lean into the
suckage
yeah that's why i want to see wicker man
again i saw it everybody laughed at it
i liked it i remember like well it's
entertaining yeah
it's not a good movie but it's
entertaining yeah well you know it
wasn't
it wasn't like a work of art like mandy
oscar said pig is good i saw it last
night yeah yeah i've heard i've heard it
was good
you just it was it streaming
i don't know my sister saw in the
theater okay
thank you zach jen i'm going to start
doing a new screenplay based on the nora
fuller case from your book ooh
neat that was a weird case the details
from it are so fascinating and creepy oh
my god like let let me read it when you
get it
marissa says i actually thought the
female version of ghostbusters was
pretty funny i didn't get the hate
either
that's kind of what a lot of people like
like i said i haven't seen it i might
see it eventually but
that's what some channels were just kind
of like i think everybody just freaked
out without seeing it because they're
like it's fine
they're like you know it's not as good
as the original but what the [ __ ] is
they're like it was still pretty funny
whatever uh
let's see it was like a true story his
lawyer got kidnapped and said his
kidnappers were letting him sleep with
girls and other crazy [ __ ] and the cops
didn't believe him but it was true
i think he's talking about the [ __ ] that
happened in florida
yeah fourth redown says a feature-length
episode of kingdom was released on
netflix a few days ago
yeah i was i saw that i thought it was
like a season two
type or i guess it would be season three
it wasn't with their two seasons of
kingdom
you remember that that was like the yeah
the one about the it was like zombies
but it was like set back in the
in the old days with samurais and
whatnot
remember that that was like really good
uh which one was it what was it called
again kingdom
yeah it was all right yeah remember we
saw that but the one there were two of
them were similar
kingdom was one of them remember yeah
and then there was another one that was
cool
well there was a series kingdom was a
series and then there was a movie
that was called monstrum yeah there was
a movie that was called monstrum that
was almost the same
premise but i think they came out like
right around the same time so it's not
like one ripped off the other it just
happened
terry said that the female ghostbusters
is a dumpster fire
yeah like i said i'm saying you know it
might be i don't know like i've never
seen it but then i've seen some other
people saying you know it was totally
fine and like they didn't really get why
i but hated it so much but you know what
i mean
everybody's gonna be the way they the
way they're gonna be
uh victor said yeah there's two seasons
i thought there were because i'm pretty
sure we did a review of that a while ago
it was like
the predator isn't that what it was
called the the last predator movie they
had all the crazy dudes in the va
yeah yeah it was okay to see it the
first time i tried to watch it again and
it wasn't anywhere near as good
it's got a lot of slow spots in it and
it
it it's not a it it didn't seem to age
well
remember remember predators they all
sound like the [ __ ] predator they all
got the same goddamn name
the one where they're on the damn yeah
yeah alien planet the one with adrian
brody in it yeah yeah
um a lot of people didn't like that when
it first came out but
that's one of my favorite ones i
actually really liked that but yeah it
gets better
it's really good it ages real well the
only thing i like about it is that the
brody guy
he's kind of doing his batman voice a
little bit um
he's kind of skinny i think he should
have been kind of a bigger dude you know
what i mean a lot of the other guys were
bigger but you know whatever
i think it would have been better with
somebody kind of like you know
uh dude from fury road somebody like
that
tom hardy like tom hardy or somebody mr
roboto says will you and jenny review
willy wonderland we did
yeah we did a matinee on it a while back
you know what's weird is that
what was i was just thinking about willy
wonderland the other day because
somebody introduced an arg what the [ __ ]
is it called
i can't remember and i don't remember
when it first started coming out but it
was almost the same exact
premise as willie's wonderland in the
sense that it was supposed to be
it was i wish i could remember the name
of it um i saw it on
the on an expo and he was talking about
it's like about uh like these found
footage like these old vhs tapes
that are supposed to be like um employee
employee training videos
of essentially like a chuck e cheese or
willy's wonderland type situation where
there was just kind of like
this animatronics and then they i don't
know if they ate people or if they like
killed people
and stuffed them inside the animatronics
or something like that but it was just
like really weird because i'm like
watching this
breakdown of this arg and i'm like oh
that sounds just like willy's wonderland
i wonder did willy's wonderland get the
idea from that or
did was that around before that or i
don't know because i know there was
another movie well five nights at
freddy's was kind of like willie's
wonderland too and that came out before
well he's wonderland was good i liked it
i liked it too yeah and i liked it like
nicholas cage didn't say this
he didn't have to say anything he was
too badass which i thought was super
funny
they should totally make a um they
should make a sequel to that he was too
bad ass to say anything
maybe he couldn't say anything i feel
like like lunch break too
he didn't take play in lunch breaks yeah
even when people were getting killed
he's just like beep beep it's lunch time
sorry checking out that's what you what
you got to you know
that's you're legally you're legally
entitled to take a lunch break and you
know you got to do it yeah
exact amount of time and he'd always
have his like soda or whatever
and uh yeah so that was one of the funny
things about that
but like i said i kind of feel like they
should make a sequel because
they need to it almost seemed like they
were setting it up for a sequel right
because it was like him and that girl
and they kind of like rode off into the
sunset and it's like you didn't know his
backstory and it's like
victor's talking about monstrum was
pretty good yeah i liked it pretty good
um i didn't like it as much as the
series but if you liked kingdom you'd
probably like monstrum as well because
it's pretty much the same
because monster was a movie you know
what i mean it was just like
self-contained
the one that was uh the korean one that
was disappointing was the uh
uh trade of busan ii peninsula peninsula
i know i really wanted to love that and
it's like i just kind of liked it
yeah i mean trying to busan was so good
it's like really hard to follow that up
the script
for peninsula just wasn't tight it
wasn't tight enough
yeah um
i think i think they tried to spread
everything a little too thin they try to
start to talk they tried to talk about
too many people
it wasn't a singular driving survival
story
yeah maybe that's what it was yeah
because i kind of feel like
because that whole movie was situational
them on that damn train
and the thing that made train to busan
great was like you said there was like a
handful of characters and they were all
really compelling
and you really gave a [ __ ] about them
like when
bad [ __ ] happened to them like that one
like that one kind of tubby guy that was
in there it's like i was like really
upset when that dude like
bought it i was like no the guy
sacrificed himself yeah
because that dude was awesome yeah and
like the end like really maybe like
really bumped me out it was like so sad
at the end
um somebody's marissa said have you all
seen mom and dad with nicolas cage
that's actually been on my list for a
while because i think it's on
it's on amazon prime or hulu i can't
remember and i keep like seeing it i'm
scrolling past what's it about
i'm not sure but it's like i just keep
seeing it like come up in my recommended
and i'm just kind of like man i need to
watch that one of these days and i just
haven't gotten around to it
yeah just pepper says uh house of leaves
would make a good tv series plus arg
combo i agree i'm surprised
actually i'm not surprised no one's
tried to adapt that because
i'm not even sure i'm not even sure how
i would go about adapting that it would
be like real i mean that somebody could
do it i'm sure
i really i'm going to reread that book
sometime before the end of the year
because i want to like review it because
so many people have asked me to do it i
read it
like a long time ago and it was so it's
so awesome it's just like like i said
it's not even a book it's just like a
whole like [ __ ] experience
so so but i'm probably gonna leave it
till the end of the year so i have like
a lot of time to like digest it you know
because it takes so long
did we do the ring yeah we did um i
didn't do the sequel though because i
didn't like the sequel
but i love the i love the ring though
what
some [ __ ] joke some [ __ ] jumped in
his name is oivay
looking and he's looking to join your
local nazis look at this oh my
goodness jump in this such an edge
glory's edge lord and this is this the
jewish boy
summer or something uh somebody deleted
him
bye-bye what are you 12
yeah [ __ ] off
his name is zoy faye oh my god i don't
know how many patients are that kind of
crap it's like just this way what is
this 2005 yeah
yeah i know get out of here
that kind of trolling is passe that's
what i mean it's like god i was sick of
that trolling when i was like [ __ ] like
[ __ ] 20 years ago
years ago 15 years however long people
probably stuck in there
i suppose yes stuck into an
earlier age yeah that's either like a
really really young person or a really
really old person
oh my god i find all that [ __ ] humorous
i'm not
about anything yeah well i'm not either
i just think it's like
it's just like they're trying to offend
people well it's just like i don't
understand why people don't
this is why this is why we can't have
nice things it's like why
why this is why [ __ ] doesn't get
accomplished because people
like so many people are busy doing
stupid [ __ ] like that it's like find
something useful to do with your time
you're [ __ ]
oh see look there's another one what's
he saying now wait child
rapist i can't even read that okay long
live
israel rape babies okay yeah yeah yeah
it's a boomer hacker
it's a problem it's a mover hacker
[Laughter]
nice try yeah but uh yeah interestingly
it probably is yeah gosh you're so
clever yeah but um
yeah so well somebody was saying the
funny thing about uh david june said
if he supports nazis what does he have
the jewish thing interestingly
the show the show that we're doing
friday night
is about uh the raelians
you know which is a cult or religion
actually the more i read about them i'm
like
they seem pretty okay um but you know
what i mean the only
like they're not they're weird but
they're not like you know
oh my god like they're gonna you're
gonna end up murdered weird like not
anything that i've seen
however they did get in a bit of hot
water because the symbol of their
religion
and they had to know that this was going
to cause problems is
a jewish star with a swastika inside
like it's kind of like a stylized
version of it you can still tell what it
is i'm like
that seemed like not the best idea but
okay who did that
the raelians the aliens did it yeah and
it re it's dumb because it really
doesn't have anything to do with their
belief system it's like why don't you
just like come up with your own [ __ ]
logo
be original so that's like the only
thing that pissed me off about them but
they were just kind of like come up with
your own [ __ ]
like you must they must have had some
something like uh you know
juxtaposition of of opposites well they
keep saying
well they keep saying they're using the
swastika like in the old
term which which like i said that it did
used to be before it was co-opted by the
nazis and now everybody like recognized
it as that but it was like
you know an actual one around for a long
time yeah like the four wins and [ __ ]
it's actually a buddhist symbol yeah
right and you still see it like on
temples and stuff over there yeah
so it doesn't you know in the west it
means something like a lot different
than it used to mean which is a shame
uh so they were trying to go back to the
original i guess they were trying to
like reclaim it
maybe but i'm like i don't know i don't
know time for that one's to pass
i i think maybe it's too late to do it
like just think of something else
you used to see it in korea they used to
use it kind of like the red cross symbol
it's like their version of like
pharmacies had that on it
you know i mean like we have a red cross
they'd have that damn swastika yeah
and it was uh kind of like
i kind of like uh not not real
pharmacies but like their versions like
homeopathic
like korean and eastern medicine
which is you know hot suction cups on
you and [ __ ] like that that that's where
you go to you know
suction cup actually you've never seen
that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it's like the
hot suction cups and all that kind of
[ __ ] that's that's what they
the hot rocks they put in yeah that was
the symbol that they had little needles
what not
was like a swastika although it's not
really i mean i always thought
somebody correct me but um i always
thought that homeopathic
that was a specific thing that
came out of the whole
the whole um counterintuitive
belief that the less of a medicine that
you put
in something like the more effective it
was which doesn't make any sense to me
but okay
um so so they dilute the medicine in
water until there's essentially like
none of it left
you know what i'm saying but then they
think that's supposed to be like even
more effective even though it's
essentially just water because they
don't know how chemistry works
so yeah that's what i mean when
something says homeopathic remedy on it
that's what i'm thinking i'm like oh so
it's just water so you might as well
just stay home and drink water out of
your tap because that's about as
effective it's gonna
same dude jumping in here asking to see
my boobs
you want to see your boots yeah of
course that's new
[Laughter]
oh my god my boobs are bigger than
[ __ ] mostly [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sleazy bees eating a live octopus and it
sticks to your throat and you suffocate
yeah
okay yeah that reminded me of uh old boy
that dude not like octopus that was
still alive it was like grabbing his
face
i was like i felt so bad for that
octopus yeah grabbing his face while
it's going it's like no
please don't need me yeah octopuses are
smart
maybe only one troll who switches
channels it's just it's probably yeah
yeah they're just they just keep
switching names yeah because like i said
they clearly don't have anything better
to do
so i don't know whatever hey somebody's
getting mentioned
he's getting mentioned that's really all
they wanted to live
yeah that's sad i find all that [ __ ]
funny i don't give a [ __ ]
oh my god why don't you just like go
jerk off or something yeah
he probably is well oh he might be
jerking off at the same time
has anyone seen the movie the lobster
not yet but that one's on my list as
well
isn't that's the one where like if you
don't wait a minute
isn't that the one we're like if you
don't oh okay oh my computer's doing
wearing [ __ ] again
um where like if you don't have sex by a
certain age like you turn into a lobster
or you turn into a monster
or an animal or something right it was
it had some weird premise like that and
i said ooh that sounds right up my alley
but i haven't got around to watching it
like i said my [ __ ] to watch movie
list
is 40 miles long
you know yeah and i just feel and every
time
i think i said this before but i was
just like every time i go through
my list like to put [ __ ] up in the poll
you know for people to vote on for the
next
review i'm just kind of like i'm
scrolling through hulu and i'm scrolling
through amazon prime and
scrolling through shutter and i'm just
like oh my god i am never going to watch
all the movies that i want to watch
because there's so many and i'm just
like oh i gotta watch that one oh [ __ ] i
wanted to see that one oh [ __ ] i just
don't have time
you know it's it sucks it sucks exactly
carpal tunnel
oh no i'm sorry zach we didn't we didn't
know that you were gonna have to be like
working tonight and [ __ ] sorry about
that
yeah no need for me too says nice thanks
zachary don't think i'd be that quick on
the draw
uh even yeah okay wait
jenny used to call me a troll until i
identify i didn't call you a troll i
just
i kept calling you what did i keep
calling him i called you a stalker
who grew up there's hate okay well
because it was because
you seem to know all this stuff about
tom but you wouldn't like say
who you are and like remember because
tom kept trying to guess like who you
were and you were like no no you were
like being all mysterious so
so i was teasing tom that i was like oh
you have a stalker
so that's kind of why so i was calling
you a stalker i didn't call you a troll
that's
that's a completely different thing
that's a completely different thing
um yeah how much like more drink do they
okay
so what else are we gonna talk about
we're gonna talk about some [ __ ]
because you know i think if i wanted to
kill someone i would use a small
crossbow or handheld modified slingshot
with a deer arrow
where did that come from
[Laughter]
focus target practice all right
zach says i like how he gets angry as i
do it this is giving me life
see it's free entertainment thank you no
need for me too
the zachary thanks fun
[Laughter]
well i mean like i said if people just
don't have anything better i don't know
it's just
it's so like pitiful it's pitiful
i don't get it sandra sanders says
grandparents was a bit creepy in the
beginning but now he's cool
i didn't like i didn't see him as creepy
i was just kind of like i figured
that it was somebody tom knew because he
seemed to know all this information and
tom was getting a little bit paranoid
because he's like who is this person and
it's like
he was trying to guess who it was i
thought it was an old girlfriend and he
guess who it was
[Laughter]
i thought it was somebody i burned in
high school some chick
she's like coming back all these years
later
i was well other than i mean other than
my friends in high school like i
remember them because i still like
you know know them on facebook and stuff
but it's like other than that i don't
think i remember a single person that i
went to high school with
it's just kind of like and it's funny i
don't know why i was thinking about this
but i was thinking about this the other
day because i feel like
people maybe it was because we were
talking to the kids and uh the kids
are not uh aaliyah nick if you guys
don't know because they haven't been out
of high school that long
and i think i was they didn't say
anything like this but i was kind of
thinking about how
people that age or when you're in high
school it seems like it's the be-all
end-all it seems like it's so [ __ ]
important like everything that happens
there is so [ __ ] important
and then like literally five or ten
years later i couldn't remember the
names of a single [ __ ] person
other than like you know friends that i
knew i couldn't remember anybody else i
couldn't really remember anything about
it
i remember a lot of it because i pretty
much had a great time
well i had a great time i had an okay
time but it's like it wasn't
i mean it really didn't affect much of
anything
i went to two different high schools
[ __ ] one and one in michigan and one
in brazil i was jumping between the two
i was just having a [ __ ] great time i
had a great time in both places
well yeah yeah but i'm just saying that
even though
like i didn't i hated junior high high
school i liked
but um you know i had a pretty good time
in high school
but other than like i said other than
like the few friends that i hung out
with
and that i still know nowadays um
i don't really remember much of anything
about it it's like really not
you know i had like two different
extremes what
trenton michigan that high school there
[ __ ] trent high was kind of like
going
going to [ __ ] hilldale out of [ __ ]
back to the future it was like that kind
of you know how [ __ ] marty mcfly's
[ __ ]
house where he came from it's like that
it's just like 100 percent all american
everybody's dad was working in [ __ ]
some kind of work some kind of car
industry
you know this is what it seemed like
just like all american grandparents will
tell you
it's just like middle class middle
upper middle class middle class [ __ ]
america america it's like that
and then i'd go to brazil and it was
like of
going into a duran duran video all right
of nothing but
his name is yeah yeah it was nothing but
just second sao paulo
night life club life
and you're a teenager you can go to
clubs and you can drink your [ __ ]
white suit on yeah
yeah and it was [ __ ] 80s running down
this run down the beach in your bare
feet yeah
[Laughter]
and you have a lot of money compared to
everybody else hot chicks with their
high hopes bikinis
yeah their bikinis like cut way over
there
brazilian girls are brazilian girls of
[ __ ] all ages were [ __ ]
you know just off the chain uh
from high school girls on up and
just it was [ __ ] it was it was
amazing it was great
and you know i went to a [ __ ]
international high school had people
from all around the world
and the brazilians that went there were
all the damn children of
[ __ ] the ruling class and the
political class
so you go yeah the country's [ __ ] up
because his dad's an [ __ ] you know
it's just like
the belugas were there you were a little
privileged [ __ ]
uh not compared to them well no not
compared but
compared to me you were yeah yeah but it
didn't seem that way
i lived in a little little bitty
two-bedroom apartment down the street
from my high school without my dad
my brother when i was when i was in
south america i was living in a duran
duran video
yeah mr roboto says so jenny you were
not the prime
the prom queen then [ __ ] no i was the
problem king i got a picture of you
i did go to the prom like with uh we
just went with a big group of friends
but we ditched about halfway in to go to
rocky horror
yeah so you know no i was that
that's what that action was all about we
were just like this is lame let's go
i was not uh [ __ ] grabbers will tell
you i was not
a alpha chad i was
more like a sigma i was [ __ ] hanging
out in the [ __ ]
guys that had bands and we were in the
theater and [ __ ] and i was hanging out
with the punk rock girls
but when i was in brazil it was just
perfect you know to [ __ ]
be who i was it was [ __ ] great it was
[ __ ] had a great time
um did everything just fit right in i
was a sigma chad i was not an alpha chad
yeah you weren't like you're not like a
jock no you're kind of like you were
kind of one of those like
all-around [ __ ] you know what i
mean where it's just kind of like
it wasn't obvious to everybody what else
what i was doing i guess
it was maybe you know i was not
i'm not a big dude and i was not big
back then
i was kind of a michael j fox type you
know
in build and size and um
you know i was just made friends with
people you know yeah sure there's people
who didn't like you
didn't like me but that's with everybody
yeah everybody
that you had haters but yeah that's the
thing i mean you're outgoing you're
funny
you're smart i know you didn't give a
[ __ ] i was just having fun
yeah and making it and trying to make
people laugh and make myself laugh
that's what i was doing zach says do
either of you feel like you really
didn't learn anything after you got out
of high school
honestly i liked school uh because i'm a
geek
um so i was like excited i really liked
i particularly liked english classes
you know art history all that kind of
stuff but i liked math and [ __ ] too
and um i did learn a lot in school but i
think i learned more after
because i like more self-directed kind
of learning
you know what i mean which in a way i
think when i was younger
you know they put me on like the gifted
track or whatever so you could kind of
do your own [ __ ] more than if you were
in the regular
so that was good but once i got out i
mean
i don't know i think i learned a lot
after i got out too because i'm not one
of those people it's like oh i'm never
reading a book ever again or i'm really
because i knew some people like that and
i just thought those people were lame
but yeah i'll like
[ __ ] yeah mr roboto saying tom were
you a jock or rotc
no i was an artist i was in a military
academy before i went
to um to trenton or
or that high school in brazil um so i
didn't
i didn't really have any there was no
there was no access to rotc
at that time i wouldn't have given a
[ __ ] about it yeah
um zach says oh jenny you have a nice
singing voice thank you
i was actually in a chorus most of i was
in chorus in all of elementary school
and in all of high school also grampur
said
something up there says tom i said i was
well liked
yeah well i can see that i can see that
just well you still are
yeah i mean that's the thing i can't
really think of that many people
actually i can't really think of anybody
that doesn't like you or if
or people like that who aren't scumbags
themselves
yeah like i don't care if scumbags think
about
ash ashwagandha or testosterone i don't
know what ashwagandha
is i've heard of that but i can't think
of what it is right now
i don't know how ashwagandha would be
for testosterone i'm not sure what it is
yeah they're talking about um what you
call it like uh
reunions and yeah dj mean axes i didn't
go to mine because [ __ ] those people
i've never been to one
i mean like i said i liked you know i
hung out with some people in my high
school and like i liked some of the
people in high school but
i'm not enough of them and it's like the
ones that i liked i still you know see
them on facebook
and still kind of keep up with them so
everybody else i didn't really care
about
yeah no but um camp guy up
because it's a natural supplement that's
supposed to elevate testosterone
okay there's a lot of stuff out there
that's
sold for um as a means to elevate
testosterone
like testosterone boosters and um
if you really want like a detailed
explanation for all that you want to
find you want to go
on youtube and look for um derek his um
channel is called um more plates more
dates
he's a young guy young [ __ ] geek
every time you say that
i think of like more dates i think of
dudes like pleat spinning
like it i know that i know that's not
what it is is it the weights and then
the tape
that's not what it is but that's the
first thing my brain gets dates i think
like dude you might have a double
meaning like
getting dates with girls or might be
dates that you're making during your
progress it might be something like that
well that's what i thought it does
doesn't really matter but um
he can give you a blow-by-blow on each
one of them and what the results are
in in blood work because he doesn't just
talk out of his ass he'll show you
medical journals and then
show you what blood results are and
he'll read right out of [ __ ]
scientific papers from the medical
industry i mean the dude sounds like a
doctor he's not he's totally
self-trained that's his he's an
intelligent guy
and that's his hobby is to know about
what all these drugs do
he takes them too he'll tell you i took
this one i took that
he's very open about whatever he did
he's big
got [ __ ] shoulders like damn bowling
balls
um his whole thing was to get [ __ ]
big but he didn't want to lose his hair
so he's
also getting all this [ __ ] about
protocols steroid protocols to keep you
from losing your hair because you start
jacking up that much anabolics oh your
hair fall out so he's trying to do two
things at once that aren't supposed to
happen but he did a good job
um that t-boosting type [ __ ]
in general there is is full of [ __ ] yeah
it'll boost your testosterone
a bit but not enough to make a
difference not enough to justify the
prices that they're asking for
um and we're talking about very slightly
if you can't get it up okay get it up if
you can't get your
if you can't get your numbers up there
that's a totally different thing
if you can't get your total testosterone
numbers up
just through sleep and diet and exercise
then there's a problem taking those t
boosters
is not going to make a difference might
go up a couple points but that will
that won't be enough in general not
enough
it's not enough one minute not but
enough to make a difference in general
you got to find out what the problem is
is it age
is that what the problem is did you take
something that suppressed your
testosterone
did you take something like sarms were
you [ __ ] around with any other
anabolics
that could shut your nuts down if so you
want to look at clomid or hc shut down
those nuts
yeah i shut them right off
[ __ ] testosterone be real low um
you want to get your hands on something
like call like clomid
or hcg which are which are um
actually made for females they're
fertility drugs
but they they work by stimulating the
pituitary gland if you take those
you can stimulate your pituitary gland
to send messages to your nuts and your
other endocrine systems to start
producing hormones
and that'll do it i didn't tell anything
on the show
but what before i went to [ __ ] and
i'm wearing it right now see
that's that's my [ __ ] doctor see
what's that say t clinics
oh i didn't know i didn't know you got
that he gave it to me gave it to me when
i went i went to go get my blood oh you
had your uh
appointment on monday i had my blood
results you didn't tell me you got a
free t-shirt give me a t-shirt because
here man here's a shirt
he goes wear that yeah right free
advertising yeah
wear that so um
when before i okay hypogonad
hypogonadism
which is [ __ ] that means you're not
making enough testosterone i think it's
around 250.
all right top of the line
top of the line [ __ ] natural free
testosterone probably around 650
that's average probably top of the line
dude in his teens who's [ __ ] kicking
ass it might be 1400
1600 1200 around there but he's not
producing that much very often it's just
gonna
come and go and certainly when he sleeps
he'll probably produce that but only for
a few hours and it'll slowly contrail
off and
when i went to first get blood work done
before i started any any of the uh any
of the therapies
my my total test was only um
160. that's [ __ ] terrible
i was feeling bad says i was jenny i
feel like i'm going to die
i knew that's what it was because that's
what some of this i knew what the
symptoms were
yeah he was having all kinds of problems
yeah i'm gonna [ __ ] die
that might have been from [ __ ] around
with sarms might have been a bunch of
[ __ ]
anyway they put you on hcg and they put
you on testosterone
after four months they tell you to come
off of all that [ __ ]
and they want to get a baseline to see
what your natural test is
i'm at 9.50 that's [ __ ] badass
that's my natural test 950.
that's that's good real good that's real
good
all right and that was that hcg the
pituitary gland stimulant did that
turned all that [ __ ] back on
yeah and then when i put test on top of
that i'm probably running fourteen
hundred sixteen hundred maybe twelve
hundred forty probably depends on
how close it was to that injection and
it's all the time 24
7 whether you're drinking or didn't get
much sleep it doesn't matter it's all
artificial so
i'm not bullshitting when i tell you i
have the testosterone of like
six big no i probably have the
testosterone of like two or three 16
year old boys
and it runs hard i'm [ __ ] constantly
hot sticky
smell smell bad yeah
gotta wash the sheets all the time just
everything gets all set it was like
skunk ape
yeah like skunk well he was kind of like
skunky before yeah it's worse like worse
you're just constantly [ __ ] sweating
sweating and sweating out [ __ ] grease
and just trimming up boys are across
yeah
fat all just burning off you saunder
says
uh jenny do you still take testosterone
do you feel anything
um not really yet uh i'm still taking it
but yeah you have to understand that a
woman's
system is not like a man's well
yeah everybody knows that actually every
woman could tell a man that yeah
you know testosterone in a woman doesn't
do exactly the same things it does for
in a man they didn't go through i don't
really feel any different
they don't go through male puberty
so they're not androgenized for it
they have it but it's 10 times less than
men
um there's some disagreement about what
replacement level is
and then what benefit level is you know
replacement pretty much we know that
that's about 20 milligrams
a week um but some
doctors say that you want benefits
that's that might be 40 to 60.
um when you start pushing
150 200 sometimes a hundred a week
over a period of a few months like a
year so you
that she will answer and androgenized to
that and become a man
i mean yeah you can't like do youtube
yeah i don't want to drink
about a [ __ ] beard so you have to
find
the doctors all agree that you have to
you have to know what replacement is
you have to find benefit which that
might be 40 milligrams that might be
60. it's trial and error it's when you
start seeing results
but you don't want to go up there and
start giving 100
or 150 or 200. you see the signs coming
you can back off you know like
hair starts growing they start getting
too lean voice starts to change
acne things like that that'll all come
first
you see that you want to back off as too
much but they just
it's very new technology the only women
that are pretty much doing it are
post-menopausal women and they're taking
very small amounts
that's one end of the spectrum the other
end of the spectrum are young women
who are in the gym they're very active
and they're
taking a pretty good amount
they don't turn into men they look great
i think i've showed pictures before
of what they look like you get lean and
muscular
but it looks like a woman you know
um people think that
women are all estrogen no
no women are pretty much all
testosterone
it's just that it's much less than a man
the t uh what gives a female
femininity is not estrogen it's
testosterone it's just it's a lot lower
levels of it
estrogen levels have a lot to do with
pregnancy it causes you to retain a lot
of water you get fat
um a highly estrogen estrogenized woman
in general you can kind of tell who they
are you can tell how strong their
they their puberty was by how much
weight they put on on the lower
end the bottom end like they got big
asses big legs
she's pretty highly estrogenized if a
woman puts on weight around the
midsection even when she's young she's
not quite as estrogenized
if she's very thin that's kinda
seems to be that they're kind of high in
testosterone um
well in comparison everything's all in a
different scale
nowhere near what a man would be but um
sir about it jenny would have the
sexiest beard
oh my god okay so you got maybe for
halloween oh i should get a beard
i want like the old school [ __ ]
victorian
like kind of van dyke type of beard with
like that mustache with like twirly kind
of [ __ ] oh
yeah now i'm gonna get that for
halloween i think i would look good like
that
yeah it might be good and she's she says
she can't
feel any difference which probably not i
believe that i believe that
but i see some differences in her it
sure hurt
why because you think i'm like saltier
you're a little bit more aggressive
yeah yeah but i'm always i'm always kind
of like that yeah before you before you
were a little
that's because i was keeping my mouth
shut yeah but you don't need to
but you don't anymore yeah but you know
what i mean it all started from around
there but in the end
you know i read up on all this
so i already knew that that would happen
um they said that
the females that are high higher in
testosterone
are combative but it's not bad
you know what i mean uh
because it's just like guys guys are
combative but they just don't take it as
personally
i wouldn't call my i don't think i'm
combative no not yet but
if i were to increase that dosages if
you were to increase those dosages you
would become
working pop you in the face no you
wouldn't do that
just talk more [ __ ] you become more
dominant
and you're more you're you're more
dominant than you were that's good
though
yeah i think i need that yeah well
because i kind of feel like
i'm kind of one of those people that
even if i don't say anything like mean
about people to their face i'm your
friend
well because i don't want i don't want
to hurt people's feelings two i don't
want people
not like disliking me i have that i have
i've always had that problem my whole
testosterone will solve that problem
so it's kind of like [ __ ] so now i'm
gonna get busted in the mouth like by
somebody because i'm gonna say something
smart
because like i said like people piss me
off all the time but it's like i'm
usually like
okay like just chill don't you know well
because it's because
um one i'm a nice person and like i said
one i don't want to hurt other people's
feelings but also
because my dad was one of those people
that would just be
like [ __ ] you man and he would just be
and i just like well i don't really want
to be like that
right um because it was like really over
the top so i didn't really want to be
like that
and then so i kind of got into this
weird place where it's like i'm thinking
really shitty
stuff about people but it's like i don't
want to say anything
to their face the the the the idea is
not to take
you outside of the female range
is to move you into the higher echelons
of the female range
you know what i'm talking about yeah and
that higher levels of aggression will be
in the female range
it won't be in the mail range it'll be
in the female range there are women that
are like that
lots of but i told him and i told him
this the other day i'm like don't
i was like don't let's not get to a
point where
if i get mad at you about something yeah
you don't just go oh it's the
testosterone
talking and just like ignore because i'm
like maybe you really did do something
[ __ ] up and i have a right to be mad
at you
well yeah you know what i mean you're
misinterpreting the way it would work
though
no i'm just saying that like let's not i
don't want that to happen i'm just
putting testosterone doesn't make you
see things that aren't there
well i never said it did i'm just saying
they're saying you're saying that oh
it's just a testosterone this you're not
this is not
a mind-altering drug like you no no
that's not what i meant that's not what
i meant
what it does is it lowers the look it
it lowers the i guess you say the
threshold of
of inhibition in other words you will
say what you're thinking instead of
[ __ ] censoring yourself
uh-oh but it's within that's healthy
though
that's healthy though uh-oh
yeah no one wants to know what i'm
thinking seriously
about honesty you know what i mean
honesty is
virtue not always why not
what do you hide sonder well i'm not
hiding anything i'm just saying
saunders said i always thought jenny's a
pretty nice girl until i heard the story
about how she pushed the girl in the
club
yeah but yeah you have to yeah
you have to understand that i had put up
with this girl's [ __ ]
for how long a long time like a year at
that point and had done nothing
i was just kind of like okay i'm just
i'm gonna be the better person
i really can't stand this [ __ ] but you
know i'm just gonna like
you took her man yeah i'm just gonna
like not
like i put up with a lot from her okay
so just like finally i'd had like so
many drinks and she just did like that
one thing it was just that one thing and
it like the straw that broke the candles
back and i'm just like look
okay i'm i'm done that's it i just so i
got to a point where i was just kind of
like [ __ ] i'm just gonna
i was i probably would have i don't
think it would have killed her
no um you better beat her ass in front
but i probably would have just
i would have punched her in the face it
was funny it had been fun it would have
been funny
it would have been funny but i well i
was like coherent enough to be
because i wasn't i wasn't drunk drunk i
was like tipsy
but i was just kind of like i was pissed
because she just kind of like did that
whole
oh sorry i bumped into you but like
really obviously did it on purpose
and i was just kind of like [ __ ] hell
because she's in germany now she's in
germany
she'd been doing that for like so long
you better watch out sandra she's in
germany now
that's right like her she hooked up with
a german guy yeah
because like i said because no one in
the u.s would put up with her
that's the joke i always made i don't
like
you know as as much as i say like i
don't hate a lot of people i don't
um but some people just like rub me the
wrong way and like ever since the first
time i met this girl she really really
rubbed me the wrong way yeah
and there was just like nothing that she
could do that would make me last time i
saw her i asked her
so what the house house jeremy because i
like germany
but the germans are [ __ ] so they are
you guys yeah they're [ __ ]
and i'm like but you're not yes as soon
as they hear you're from america they
start treating you like [ __ ] i'm like
maybe that's just you yeah
i don't know because she's kind of a
douche yeah
but i don't i don't know she's aware of
it though no she's crazy she doesn't
seem to be aware of like of what a
douche she was or how she came across to
people
because i talked to other people about
it and even people that like worked at
that
i'm not naming any names and it's like
you know they they would immediately
look if i say oh this [ __ ] is doing
this they would go oh is it this or i'm
like yeah how'd you know and they're
just like oh yeah
yeah yeah everybody knew like she had a
reputation of just me but i don't think
she was aware of it
so it's like which in a way is kind of
sad because she didn't know that
everyone just thought she was annoying
as [ __ ]
but yeah you know yeah that was that
whole touch i'm not gonna say what her
name was or nothing like that but
yeah there was some she there was a
little bit of a
would i call it a stalker situation it
was a little bit like a stalkery
situation
yeah because did we tell that story was
that this was like years and years and
years ago
years and years ago and i think it was
even before we were like officially
officially
but we were kept we were like would go
out together all the time
yeah um you know and drive friends and
whatnot and then sometimes like he'd
sleep over my apartment or i'd sleep
over at his house or whatever
because it was closer and so this one
night
i was gonna sleep at his house like all
my [ __ ] was already there
and we were driving another friend home
and then she kept calling him
and we were like i remember we're like
in the drive-through like at [ __ ]
mcdonald's or taco bell or whatever
and she kept like calling and she said
to you i'm coming to your house right
now
yeah yeah and then you told
you she's like no jenny's staying at my
house yeah and she was like wigging out
and i said
i told you and i remember telling you
this i said if this [ __ ] is in your
bushes
when we get back to your house i'm just
gonna be like
i said do i have your permission to like
at least beat her ass she couldn't
believe i was going out with you
i know she couldn't believe it
because i'm so lame yeah in her mind
she's another huge insult oscar
oscar said that derek is a huge mother i
think he's talking about derek from
dates
more from more plates somebody asked
earlier
um is that you talking about derek yeah
somebody asked earlier if you have a
small dick does it matter
like if you're like super big like will
it get you more dates like being
like super muscular uh no if you have
like a super small day i don't think
well honestly if you have a super small
dick and like i said i'm not hating
because i know some people just haven't
there's like not a lot
yeah um so basically i would recommend
just like cultivating other
uh other things because you know
everybody has [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
about them
like everybody nobody's perfect um so
you just gotta like put your energy into
other stuff and honestly i kind of feel
like
women are pretty uh forgiving of that
kind of [ __ ] if you have like a bunch of
other stuff to offer
i mean i was never super bothered by i
don't know
i think it depends on who you are as a
guy and what how high you're shooting
i've known guys that [ __ ] had that
problem and [ __ ] they were
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah
you know you know one of them yeah you
know exactly what i'm talking about
yeah so it's like i said and he works
out
uh but that dude likes real hot
women that look [ __ ] gorgeous and
[ __ ] he's big into that
uh no women like that can women that are
hot the hotter they are the more they
have their pick and chews
more they can pick and choose through
guys and the more predatory they are too
i mean
it's something you know i've i've only
been with good looking women you know
and uh you got to watch them you know
the better looking they are the more you
got
to watch it the better looking they are
the more predatory they are especially
when they're
young all right and uh no there's a lot
of women over there [ __ ]
and he told you they'll sleep with them
once and they won't come back they're
like well because like i said at that
age when they're younger and they're
like super hot
they know that they can pick and choose
they're picking and choosing yeah you
know
they want a dude who's looks good
young fun rich
big dick good shape got a lot of drugs
got a lot of money
all the [ __ ] that doesn't happen in one
dude they want all that at once
that usually doesn't all happen in one
dude but that's like you that they're
behind
well and not all young women obviously
but some like super hot young women tend
to be like
tend to be like not all of them because
i knew some that weren't but not all
but the ones that give off that gold
digger vibe
are like that yeah and
you know problem being i kind of feel
like
that dudes that there are dudes that are
just like that
well there are but it's like i do kind
of feel like that ever like all the
dudes want those like
0.01 of women yeah and it's like they're
not gonna get that
right so because there's like i said
they can pick
whoever they [ __ ] they want so it's kind
of like and that's like a small
percentage
anyway yeah so you're really kind of
setting your up
and you know that's kind of when you
talk about those retards like [ __ ]
you know elliot roger and [ __ ] like that
where it's just kind of like oh well
this super hot girl who can pick anybody
doesn't like me
specifically so all women suck yeah and
then they just start shooting people up
which is
stupid as i mean that's not exactly how
it happens but
no but i'm just saying that's kind of
like what their thought process
is sort of like right like you think
because
the super hot women don't notice you or
you don't like i did this and that like
what else do you
think that they deserve these right
that's a big that's very dangerous thing
to think
no one deserves anything they think they
deserve these hot ass women
and you look at the dude and he's
[ __ ] way overweight
doesn't have a badass job doesn't really
have a pot to piss in
that doesn't really have a good
personality he's not even funny
so why does he deserve this woman
you know what i mean why should he get
this [ __ ] top echelon woman
should a bum with pissy ass his pants
and [ __ ]
and kiss he has pissed he has pissed
pants
and a bottle of mad dog 20 20. should he
be getting that five pieces
is he going to give me a sip from the
bad 20 20. because maybe i'll think
about it
you know so no when it comes to those
available women
available [ __ ] hot women ninety
percent of them are chasing out of the
[ __ ] top five percent of those men
that ninety percent ever chasing five
percent
they're not really looking at the
mediocre guys they're definitely not
looking at the guys that don't really
have anything
about them because why do you stand out
why would you stand out to that woman
well that's the thing and i think that
and it's not just
men like everybody yeah you have to at
least have something
to offer like nobody you know everybody
has different proclivities everybody has
different interests
rogers walking down the street passing
all these 40
50 and 30 year old female mud ducks he
didn't even notice them
they were up for him but he didn't
notice it well [ __ ] even he's like like
decent looking women
probably because he was a bad he wasn't
all right looking dude he had money
his mind was altered but if his
personality wasn't so repellent
maybe well the problem with elliot
rogers and that [ __ ] troll had
elliott rogers in his screen name is
yeah
that's why i thought of it the the thing
with elliot rogers is that elliot rogers
was not
was mentally ill that's what it was that
wasn't
let me go ahead and fill these drinks
yeah good idea yeah
yeah that's the thing i think that's
kind of like what everybody
[Music]
that's the same one no one deserves
anything or anybody
like don't think about things that way
and also
you know what i think it's more like you
should think about
what do you have like to offer other
people and it doesn't have to be you
don't have to have like a zillion
dollars you don't have to like a big
dick you don't have anything like that
but you just have to be are you fun to
be around are you smart are you funny
it's like you know
it's just i don't know there's like lots
of things and like i said there's
billions of people in the world it's
like
there's somebody out there that'll dig
your particular [ __ ]
you know there's probably like there's
probably several people out there that
would dig your particular [ __ ]
so that's i don't know it's and that was
it took me like a really
long time to learn that an
embarrassingly long time
uh to be honest with you uh probably
until i was in my
30s so even though like i was married
when i was younger
but i don't know i still has had a lot
of issues i still have issues
but i'm you know i'm a lot better than i
used to be but it
honestly it took me until like my mid to
late 30s until i figured out
not everyone has to like you you don't
have to be
you know the hottest chick in the room
you don't have to be this you don't have
to be that
it took me a long time to figure out not
everybody has to like you
you know what i mean i kind of feel like
i kind of felt like for a long time in
my youth if everybody doesn't like me
then i have failed you know what i mean
and that's like a [ __ ] up way to go
about things
but i don't know where i got that idea
from but
that messed up a lot of my youth i have
to say so
just just saying like please don't think
that don't be don't be afraid to be
disliked
because it took me a really long time to
learn that um
thank you very much yeah they got um
i don't know i'll go on youtube they got
this one guy i forgot his name his
name's vlad
something or other and he's got a little
little [ __ ] animation of him you know
he's like a little vampire and what
he'll do is
he's on youtube i forgot his names maybe
you guys could drop it in the comment
section
but he'll uh
upload interviews on the street or
whatever
of other people who've or he'll just
steal some
chicks video talking about the guy that
she wants or like [ __ ]
likes her dating complaints about men
and he'll
post it up and kind of dissect what
she's saying
and kind of like kind of lampoon what
what
what
the woman's saying you know i call her
woman they're girls really from my point
of view they're talking about women in
their 20s you know this is still a good
kind of they're still women i mean i
kind of feel like girl is under 18.
nowadays it seems like the [ __ ] at 25
30 they're still kind of like
uh they're kind of behind in some ways
you know i mean i think
internet i think it's kind of stunning
some people's emotional growth
compared to when i growing up okay look
this this is how [ __ ] hardcore my
me growing up in brazil i'm doing a
grandpa ramble i'm on grandpa
growing up in brazil i'd go to the
[ __ ] club
and run into [ __ ] 16 year old girls
in there [ __ ] turning tricks
that's how [ __ ] advanced well
poverty you grew up fast well they do
that here too but it's like it's not
really something to be celebrated though
no
it's like it's desperation it's well
what it is it's a much
harder life okay yeah so they were
forced to grow up
quickly you know because they got bills
to pay you know
um so you know
but mostly what he's got on there is
very kind of like pampered up on upper
middle class girls this is who he's
talking about
he's a white guy so that's what he's
focusing on it seems like
and those girls are
pampered compared to a lot of you know
to a lot of other people
but yeah he'll pull the video apart
and say yeah she's she's uh she's
contradicting herself and
yeah she's she's not making sense but
the thing is is you gotta understand
that
a lot of women that are that age they
really don't know what they want
they meet some guy they like him and
they go with him but before she
before she met that guy she'd say so i
will never go out with a guy who's
you know under 5 10. so i think that's
like
unfair because it's two completely
different situations
if somebody had asked me when i was
single like what are you looking for
one i don't [ __ ] know right okay so
i'm gonna like come up with some [ __ ] i
don't know
like no one's standing in front of me
right i'll know it when i see
you know when you see it i'll know it
when i meet the person you're disagreed
with you just agree right
that's what i mean so it's like a dumb
thing right so he's up there [ __ ]
grandstanding this is probably
like a 22 or 23 year old guy making this
video look at these women
look at these women women being crazy
look how dumb they're they see
we'll never they don't even know what
what they want yeah
well no his whole thing is says look man
we're never gonna get laid
that's basically that's what he's like
maybe you're never gonna get laid
they're turning you know
and and maybe stop being such a dish and
someone might
and give me something i don't even want
to get in the comments sections i'll
look in the comment section is what the
other young
youngsters are saying in there and i'm
just like going please dudes are [ __ ]
dude
please do just set on novice these
[ __ ] are basic
because you want to go in there and say
dude you're overthinking this [ __ ]
well they are big time well
really overthinking this [ __ ] just go in
the club have a [ __ ] good time
don't focus on trying to get up this
girl's skirts man just go in there and
[ __ ]
have fun and make [ __ ] friends this
is the number one stop
trying to get up these [ __ ] women's
skirts that way that's not how you do it
the dudes are goal-oriented
women can smell that [ __ ] a mile away
you don't go to a club
do that just don't do that that's all
it's like i'm gonna go to the club i'm
gonna get laid like don't
have that mindset just you won't get
laid yourself of that mindset
because you come across as desperate and
grasping and creepy
and you just whether you realize it or
not that's how you're coming across
it's just like go because you want to go
because you like to dance because you
like to have a good time because you
want to hang out with your friends
don't worry about it yeah just let it
happen
let it happen that's that exact same in
mind thank you zach i agree with tom it
feels like the nut is kind of damaged
how we communicate in person over the
last decade
i think it's made us a lot more
suspicious and untrusting of each other
too and it kind of scares me
yeah i don't know like i guess but
i don't know i was never big on like
ginny's not big into the online culture
right now
well she works too much and she doesn't
really
follow [ __ ] like you know top
youtubers or
well i do to an extent but it's in my
own kind of
niche in the niche i'm real into like
horror movies like writers
uh you know movies yeah that type of
[ __ ]
uh you know goth [ __ ] i'm all into that
kind of stuff
so i'm kind of up on that but all this
kind of like on like all these trolling
and like all this kind of i can't like
that just gives me a headache
a lot of this in-cell action and all
this i read articles about that because
i find that interesting because i don't
like what the [ __ ] is the matter with
them even but
um but yes i don't watch any of their
channels because like i said i'd
probably just like explode
with rage yeah and i don't need that for
my blood pressure
you know yeah well
i i hear that [ __ ] and [ __ ] to me
it's like man these dudes are losers
they they're overthinking yeah
they're overthinking this [ __ ] and it
makes you wonder what they look like
now what you doing pokey well look at
pokey what's up what's the matter
she's like let's do well pay attention
to it see unlike you [ __ ] kids
i grew up in the old internet the old
school internet back when prodigy was
out and [ __ ]
i think a lot of the travelers that were
old like internet
that was back where it was you know
where dudes would actually show what
they look like and [ __ ]
dudes famous dudes that were on the
internet in these [ __ ] message groups
and [ __ ]
were [ __ ] super overweight in a
[ __ ] filthy basement with [ __ ]
all kinds of stacks of [ __ ] and just
it's just only like a nerd was on a
down computer you know and those little
guy
i like the channel wang on you on
youtube
because wayne [ __ ] will talk about
those old days in the eight of the 90s
a [ __ ] big long internet dramas
happening on some [ __ ]
irc or something the flame wars
a veteran of the flame wars of the 95
and [ __ ] the main 90s flame wars i
remember was the
mike versus joel wars on the mst boards
i remember that which to me again
seemed pointless because i'm like
they're both good they're different
because you know i'm like diplomatic and
plus i like both of them it just depends
on what mood you're in
but it's just like funny how [ __ ]
emotional people got about it and i was
just kind of like
i don't know even back then i was kind
of like i think that we have more
problems in the world like to worry
about than
than this and it's like why are people
getting so upset about this
and even now i can't like tom loves that
[ __ ] he loves like
you know channels that are like all
conflict and yelling and stuff
i call like all the channels that he
likes i just call them collectively the
yelling channel
even though they're all different uh
because it just seems like there's
always somebody shrieking
and it's like every time i go in there
to put laundry around something i'm
like just please turn that down but um
yeah so he kind of likes like some like
people like
calling out other people and like making
fun of other people i can't watch it
like that it's just to me it's
annoying i don't know it's just annoying
to me and i was like i don't really get
why
because i know that some you know and i
know that we'd probably have like a lot
more like i'd probably make a lot more
money online if
my whole channel was just like [ __ ]
on other people but it's just like i'm
not
that kind of person i don't like
watching that kind of content
um i know other people do but it's not
really my thing
i don't really like i like watching
content about [ __ ] i like you know what
i mean it's like i like watching
people that are passionate about what
they like you know if it was goth [ __ ]
or it's like you know i like
people that are really into like movie
analysis or people that are really like
history and people like that
and they're really really into it and
are like really geeky about it i like
that kind of [ __ ]
i don't really like this kind of like
let's make fun of this stupid thing i
don't i can't really watch that kind of
stuff it's just
i don't know if it's because i'm old or
i don't know it's just not my
personality
it's like and so a lot of times like i
said tom loves says [ __ ] like that i
don't like it
it's just good i don't know it just gets
on my [ __ ] nerves because he was we
were talking about it one day and he's
just like oh well he was telling me
about this channel that channel they
have this many subscribers they have
that many subscribers
and it's just kind of like you know yeah
i could probably make more money off of
it but
i don't know i just don't i just don't
know i said
that it seems like a lot of not not all
of them obviously but a lot of kind of
top youtube channels are just people
like [ __ ] on other people or like
making fun of other people
yeah and it's like fighting and i don't
it's just like i don't
i don't like that if i had to do that
for a living it would be just like
having a shitty job for a living
you know what i mean it's just it's not
my personality i don't like it
if i'm and i was telling them i said if
i'm gonna watch content on youtube
i like people that are really into
[ __ ] i don't really like watching people
that are like oh let's [ __ ] on this
stupid thing i don't really that's
i don't know it's just annoying and
juvenile and i just i don't like it i
don't like it
i got a feeling that um i got a feeling
that youtube is going to become
uncool eventually there's going to be
new ones opening it up well everybody's
going to tick-tock and all that stuff
it's too short though it's not good for
our for our well i know that but i'm
just saying that a lot of people are
kind of over i got a feeling that
odyssey's going to be really good
i like odyssey they're still building it
they're building up a lot of [ __ ] on
there
and it's going to have it's going to be
a little more underground
um the problem is that if you buy a
smart tv now the [ __ ] system that
it's running
will allow you very easily to get into
into youtube they want you on youtube
it's got a big corporate back and google
and [ __ ] you know what i mean
but if you try to do odyssey from there
you
you you have to get an app and then you
you can't find the app or it won't let
you download the app
your tv or it will [ __ ] stall out on
you
well a lot of those new startup ones are
kind of like not
really that well because they've kind of
stolen their code from other ones and
they're not really that well
integrated and all this other kind of
stuff they have to be kind of well
established for
it all to work right odyssey's new but
that's what i'm saying it has a lot of
money behind
it it's it's growing very rapidly just
pepper says are you watching the yelling
channel
i actually i got that from an episode
oh an episode of mystery science theater
i'm pretty sure it was touch of satan
because there was like there was a scene
where like the two old people were down
watching tv and it was just like i don't
remember what it was but it was somebody
who was yelling and like
crow or servo was just like boy i sure
already loved the yelling channel and i
was just like oh that sounds like what
tom watches all the time yeah yeah
that's why i call it the yelling chill
if those dudes aren't yelling
because every time i go in there like
put laundry away like oh he's watching
the yelling channel again
if those dudes aren't yelling then the
[ __ ] then it's not serious you gotta
[ __ ] yell man
do you yeah you you don't hell yeah no
you never
i'm gonna increase your dosage then
yelling will make a lot more sense
please don't
okay please don't um yeah i i don't get
excited you're gonna [ __ ] yell about
it
i don't want to be like that though
you're gonna put that npr voice in and
today
we're gonna talk about are you people
ready today today
we're gonna have a show the show is tom
and jenny tom and jenny's show
see how i know do you know what
you know what channel i've been getting
for the last couple days for whatever
reason i don't know why
but the last couple days i've been
binging i've been subscribed to her for
a long time but i haven't like binged
our videos
there's a girl named a woman named jade
the libra
and she is just all about spooky [ __ ]
halloween
all that kind of stuff um i first found
her
because she was doing a book review i
can't remember what book it was
and uh so i started on that i'm like oh
man she seems pretty cool and then like
she has all these [ __ ]
videos that are her going like
shopping for halloween decorations like
she goes to all these short stores like
michaels and stuff and like looking she
films like all the halloween decorations
and i'm like oh my god
i'm all about this and she is super she
is like
stupid stupid beautiful yeah and
she's just like and she's so [ __ ]
funny and it's like her voice is just
like really relaxing also
i totally watched a 40-minute video
of her dyeing her hair she had it like
bleached that was
like that kind of ash gray white kind of
color and it was like really awesome
looking
but she recently dyed it bright orange
and it looks fabulous it looks
fabulous and she had like this 40 minute
video of her like doing it and it was
just like
it was just like really relaxing like
watching her just like dire air orange
and it looked like so cool at the end
it's funny because i have
a big thing that sandra said i have
heard
but it does it's not there well maybe
it's up here
i don't think so unless you what are you
looking at look at what she said right
here
wait i can't see it mango wants to take
a bath of sleazy bee jenny pushes girls
into in clubs and tom talked about of
course testosterone but that's not in
your
[Music]
uh
yeah it's it missed that that comment
and then right after that she said and
flat feet and see and flat feet is there
oh okay see well i don't know i i don't
know what's
nothing errors for some reason well
sometimes it drops it drops sentences
i don't know maybe it's just a glitch to
like chill out yeah well i want to know
this kind of thing
you want to know this kind of thing this
kind of thing
i don't know what what sam is talking
about we talk about flat feet of course
we talk about flat and somebody must be
asking what would have been talking
about flat feet
um talking about testosterone i talked
about pushing girls in clubs
i didn't just push her i put i didn't
just push her i i
put my hand she grabbed her throat i put
my hand in her throat like that
and like put her over them because
there's like there's a dance floor and
then there's like a raised dance floor
that has like a
rail around it so drunk as people fall
off and um
and i pushed her against that and i like
kind of strangled her
like that like i wasn't gonna kill her
maybe
nah i might have you pulled me off
though it was funny she didn't get mad
well and then well no she did because
then
she went and reported it to lee
yeah and lee went out and then lee went
[ __ ] off because because he didn't like
it
nobody likes her well because as soon as
like she he's like well who did that and
she said oh it was jenny and he's just
like have fun yeah get out of here
well because they knew that she [ __ ]
gets in people's faces
well yeah so she's like yeah you
probably had a couple of grown women too
it was always a while ago
that was a long time it was a long time
ago but like i said i
put up like i said you were in your late
30s i think weren't you yeah i put
maybe early 40s i put up with a lot from
her though
yeah i mean and i didn't do anything she
was bullying you
yeah yeah but she and she was doing that
like passive aggressive [ __ ] that i
hate yeah
and it's just kind of like and finally
like that night i was like you know what
[ __ ] this
it's like why why am i putting up with
this [ __ ] from this i mean
roscoe says does testosterone give him
big arms she's actually lifted
i lift weights [ __ ]
yeah he's got a gym in the garage
everything i lifted two years before i
took the test i've only been on tests
for
four months and um the first couple
months there
you really couldn't tell i actually
stopped
working out the first couple months
because i could feel it just [ __ ]
healing a bunch of [ __ ] because
i was kind of worn down during that time
no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] uh laugh
however you [ __ ] want this is [ __ ]
florida all right
ponce de leon was here
for the fountain of youth and i [ __ ]
found it
he thought he found it he said augustine
yeah there was santa
there's a park there he thought he found
it i actually did found it that
that was it's just sulfur water i did
find it is exactly what [ __ ]
exactly what he described it's that
[ __ ] testosterone
yeah it fixes everything dom the bomb
says jenny who are you talking about i
don't
really i don't want to say her name um
but it's this [ __ ] that used to um
hang out with the club and she's gone
now she's moved to europe
uh but she used to [ __ ] with me all the
time because she was after tom
for a long time and uh it was like a
weird like i said
she wanted to fight for her man a
quasi-stalker situation
well no she just got on my [ __ ]
nerves man fight for her man
holy crap just knock it off with that
[ __ ] i'm too old for that
yeah just be cool if you can't be cool
get out of my [ __ ] face
and it's just and it's weird because i
don't know why she was so insistent like
after a while
because i really don't like her and i
don't want to like talk to her and stuff
it's like you still talk to
her but yeah and after a while you were
like why don't you be nice to her
because i'm like well why should i i'm
too old to like be nice to people that i
don't have to be nice well like she's
not my [ __ ] family i don't give a
[ __ ]
so one time she brought her super
annoying sister who was almost as
annoying as she was
and the sister is like coming and like
getting in my face my sister thinks you
don't like her i'm like i don't [ __ ]
like her and why you in my face just
like why
i don't understand i don't understand
i'm too old to like have to put up with
people that i don't want to put up with
anymore you know what i'm saying yeah it
was that kind of situation
so i spent so many years not being an
[ __ ]
so i'm making up for a lot of czb says
that a lot of comments get
automatically retracted because of
what's in there certain like
words are flagged he says because his
name is sleazy
he thinks he gets his [ __ ] [ __ ] i
don't know i see all your stuff though
yeah we're seeing it yeah i see
everything
i mean i don't i don't know why sleeves
would be banned i've seen stuff where
um i think the only thing i don't know
like because you can do
like filters and [ __ ] i think the only
thing that's automatic is if you put a
link
in a comment like a lot of times it'll
it doesn't delete it but it'll send it
to spam and then it'll
you have to look and say oh okay this
one's okay
they put it in like a little holding
tank for you to look at
you know what i'm saying if it's
questionable um
because you know sometimes like somebody
that we know has made like a comment
and it maybe had like a flag word or
something but it doesn't delete it it
puts it in
um hey look at this yeah situation and
then like if you look at it and it's
fine then you like just say okay that
one's okay
mr roboto says tom is a catch yes he is
uh you know and and there was a whole
situation about that
it was a whole situation uh thank you
david thompson
we had to fight for him she fought she
actually did fight for me i got some
yeah she did
i was so mad it's not only that like
there's other couple
couple other girls she fought against
of one of them you resisted
you protested and protested wait who are
we talking about
well just to get it's just disney
princess
you're like she's gonna [ __ ] you over
she's a piece of [ __ ]
and then i was thinking yeah yeah i'm
gonna get that [ __ ] first though
and if i can until then i got mad and
just dated another dude yeah yeah
it didn't matter we weren't dating each
other no that time we were just friends
but then then uh and uh yeah
i [ __ ] got sick of her ass
well she kind of made the rounds yeah
well everybody was sick of her by that
time though
she didn't last much longer after that
she started getting a bad reputation
then all of a sudden she wasn't too cool
i haven't seen her a long time i don't
know
she got married oh okay got married
moved away see there's somebody for
everybody
[Laughter]
she buried a [ __ ] chad like a full-on
[ __ ] well that doesn't shock voice
that doesn't surprise you yeah oh my god
he knows nothing about her probably
i don't know like how that and i'm not
slut-shaming i don't slutching
because you know we all went through
that uh that
phase i just said i had fun but uh you
know
it's it's just kind of like xanada says
he can't chant on this [ __ ] channel
at all
thank you david he's currently on the
road y'all make for good traveling noise
oh thank you
man look what names the troll earlier
had yeah i saw some of them but like i
said zach was like pretty quick on the
draw
like uh deleting the comments and i
guess he i guess the
poor little troll sad little troll got
tired and like wandered off
sorry 12 year old it's past his bedtime
i guess he ran out of he ran out of
[ __ ] uh
he couldn't think of any more like no he
he had defensive names no he had all
those accounts made up he ran out of
them
it's like how sad a person do you have
to be
to just be like put hey i'm gonna put
the n-word in my
title i'm gonna put like elliot roger's
name it's like oh everyone's so offended
it's like no one's offended everyone
just thinks you're a dumb ass so
good job actually the troll might have
been google
you never can tell they got robots that
do that
they got robots that can pick up on
keywords and then google consent or an
enemy computer in another country
can send a troll to to that channel
and start doing that kind of stuff and
uh
we mentioned uh we said we mentioned
some that jewish guy from new york
remember
and then that appeared that might have
just been a robot
yeah maybe never you didn't ever can't
tell i don't know well if you look at
the thing is is that youtube has pretty
good
security against robot attacks
i think some of the bot attacks they
sponsor
uh i know that they launch bot attacks
against their competitors
like google bought attacks
uh bit shoot constantly all the bit
shoot comments have [ __ ]
robotic uh [ __ ] comments underneath
them with all bunch of [ __ ] racial
slurs and this and that and they're
trying to make
bit shoot look real toxic to keep
customers
from youtube to go over to bitshoot
because bitshoot doesn't have any
security
so every bit shoot videos has [ __ ]
[ __ ] real inflammatory comments and
it doesn't have anything to do with
doesn't have anything to do with the
topic of the video
it's just being spammed with it but
and i've heard that it was you know most
people think it's google doing it
but some of it could be other companies
from other countries too
i don't think i've ever because we
posted on bit shoot for a while i don't
think i've ever got
a single comment on any video over there
except maybe
one or two like like years ago but since
then i haven't got anything
the live streams are all listened to
they're all monitored in real time by ai
uh it monitors the comment section
what's being written
and it monitors what people are saying
the robots don't understand of course
but they're they're programmed to
respond in certain ways depending on
what the topic is and it could be that
they try to drive
certain subjects off of their platform
by doing that
or you know it might be it may not be
google doing that it might be
an enemy computer from another service
doing that
it's difficult to tell there's all kinds
of weird [ __ ] happening in the internet
because that's
just kind of it yeah there's all kinds
of weird [ __ ] it happens in the internet
robot overlords yeah they tried
they well there's nothing my ass could
do about it so it's cyber war
it's a bunch of different factions
fighting over the internet
for weird reasons i think most of its
businesses business
is trying to be honest um you know and
we
talk about a bunch of crazy [ __ ] on this
show
uh you know the drunker we get the
crazier the [ __ ] is and i don't even
remember half of it
but for all that
we really don't i we don't get that many
abusive comments
and we're not that big well yeah that's
why that's true
i mean every now and then i'll get like
and it's usually like an
older video i have to say the um
the oldies that are the classics the
[ __ ] [ __ ] with about the [ __ ]
what's her face uh ed and lorraine and
warren our number one show
i think that still gets the most hateful
comments but
you know i get they're kind of sprinkled
but i don't really get that many
because normally like i said if i get
like a shitty comment i'm just like
whatever and i just delete it
you get real thick skin doing this but
it's it yeah because i don't like they
don't know me
yeah so why i don't care and it always
and like and
in a way it's kind of the only way it
offends me it's like why the [ __ ] do you
think that i would care
what you think about me because who the
[ __ ] are you what's
funny is it's the same statement over
and over again it's the same
tactic over and over again and it's it's
like
something a child does and
it's not new it's the same thing over
and over again and you see it everywhere
on all platforms yeah it's not very
creative and i think a lot of it is not
humans i think a lot of it is robots
dude i haven't seen hate comments on
like [ __ ] adorable cat videos yeah
yeah which seriously get the [ __ ] out of
here who dislikes that
i don't know yeah like i said there's no
proof that those are humans
some of those could be robots sleazy b
said figured the scientology video would
get a lot of hate i thought that too
yeah no but honestly yeah i don't really
think i don't really get
i can't remember the last time i got a
hateful comment on one of the
scientology and we've done it several
we've done because we did two or three
with angry gay pope right
and and lorraine warren have a lot of
christian fundamentalist
fans yeah and those people are kind of
the worst
yeah they do not christian
fundamentalists do not
want you um pissing on certain sacred
cows that they have
i kind of understand it you know i can't
i came out of christian schools
i know the thinking but i don't i can't
understand the
fundamentalist aspect of it you know
what i mean about
trying to adhere to something that is
obviously not true
certain aspects yeah because i mean
people will comment [ __ ] like
uh demons are real yeah it's not
anywhere you're talking about i'm just
like okay whatever or that there were no
dinosaurs or that dinosaurs were only 5
000 years ago
and that the earth is not created
which don't even get me started on that
because that's that's creationists are
actually uh one of my least favorite
types of people
i don't know there's a lot a lot of
competition there right but creationists
arrive
also um the christian
apocalypse following um i was big into
that as a kid
all that nostradamus stuff and the
[ __ ] merging nostradamus in with the
book of revelations and trying to
tell the future and the end of the world
the antichrist and the [ __ ]
the seven that the seven headed beast
here's the thing if you're
that [ __ ] religious if you're that
christian
you should know all about that book and
understand exactly what that is
they don't though but they don't
atheists know it better than the
atheists do know it better than
because of every poll imaginable has
shown that
you have to understand that preachers
have a vested
interest in telling you a certain
narrative that keeps you in the church
and keeps you donating money
you have to go back to historians and
people that really can read that
in in in in it's in its original text
and how it what world they're talking
about they're talking about the word
the roman world um
and it's fascinating yeah and it's
really sad because people that like
think all that [ __ ] is real
it's almost kind of like they can't
enjoy it for
for what it is for what it is which is a
shame and then and as well
christians believe but no no no no
christians do not believe that
all right the the eastern orthodox does
not have the book of revelations
their scholars knew that it was a
false prophecy that did not happen rome
did not fall to the antichrist
rome became the world's first christian
empire
so of course it's a false it's false
you know there wasn't a war between the
antichrist and angels and demons and
and and and and rome it happened in
another dimension
bro the roman empire wasn't destroyed it
converted it converted to christianity
so that right there the um it was not a
true the prophecy had failed
it was a cool prophecy though it had a
lot of imagery
and in the day that it was written it
probably was not marketed it was
definitely not marketed as the word of
god
it was kind of like a dude warning about
a possible future
and you know i guess you could say
it was kind of like the christian
version of an alex jones
saying they're coming and we're going to
have to fight them and once we fight him
we're going to win and we're going to
have a christian kingdom on earth and
god's going to come down to make a city
and we're all going to live in it well
like i said
humans don't change yeah there are only
so many like frameworks within like our
storytelling
goals so it's kind of like i mean that's
why like across cultures you see like
same themes like coming up again and
again
and that's why because like i said we
only have so many
modes yeah um so that doesn't mean any
of it's true
but i don't that doesn't make it any
less
fascinating i don't think like i'm
really interested in like
in that kind of show yeah what
revelation gives you
is a lot of is a lot of visual and
cultural
imagery that you can use to describe
something if if you know the if you know
that culture
well if you know this book like for
instance when you say the word
apocalyptic
that's the thing that comes to mind the
apocalypse the revelation
in revelation the apocalypse means
revelation
so you know the greek title for the book
of revelation is apocalypse
i'm going to show you something that's
what that's all it means
and it's just a weird imagery you know a
beast with seven heads and all the horns
and
that's a good drug maybe and it's and
it's just a picture
an encoded picture of of the city of
rome and how many emperors had passed
the emperor that you have now and then
the the emperor to come
and and the dudes [ __ ] laying out a
badass [ __ ]
conspiracy theory i guess you could say
it's like the conspiracy theory of the
day
well yeah it was like those dan brown
novels man where it's like all like the
da vinci code and all that
but it was like way back then yeah let
him who have understanding
reckon the number of the beast because
the number of a man that [ __ ] come on
yeah yeah yeah he did it
well roman would know exactly what you
were talking about at that time
and we talked about this the thing about
it is that
a lot of the context the cultural
context has been lost yeah
we don't live back then and we were
talking about this
when because we did um a movie
retrospective on carnival of souls
which came out in 1962 and that'll be up
friday or thursday if you're a patron
so we were just talking about and this
is just 1962.
we're talking about how the cultural
context of that movie has changed so
much
that there was one particular character
where like we're really not sure
like how you were supposed to perceive
that dude so imagine
like extrapolating back thousands of
years
and that's just like compounded right
because you're going back that far in
history
you have no idea yes humans are similar
our brains are the same
we kind of go along the same tracks and
whatever
but the culture back then was so
different and
the whole context the whole what's the
matter pokemon trying to get me to do
something
she keeps like jumping up in the chair
you know the whole um
you know situation the whole like uh you
know [ __ ] they would have understood
is so different for them that it's
really easy for us to read
modern [ __ ] into [ __ ] from back then
and it really it's not the same it's not
the same so
i don't know but that kind of [ __ ] like
interests me though
and honestly one of the best things i
ever saw i wish i could remember this i
think i've mentioned it before
one of the best things i ever saw on
youtube was this series
and [ __ ] man i can't remember it was a
long time ago it was probably like five
or six years ago that we watched it
but it was this whole series and the
dude was making an
argument that a lot of the stuff that
was in
which i don't remember if it was like
just specifically revelation or if it
was like some other
like biblical [ __ ] too but it was like
all like astrology
based like or you know based on like
constellations and stuff
and it was just like it was really
really compelling and i was just like
man
i can't believe like that's the first
time i'm hearing about that it was just
like it was really really good it's
really interesting
i guess she doesn't want to go out she
just wants to pass her well she just
wants attention
yeah bring her up in the laps come here
let her be on the show but he wants to
see pookie come on
come here pookie look everybody wants to
see look there's
pookie hi sweet pea hey
she's like yeah here i am up on the lap
so let me get up
yeah i'm gonna go play in the closet
book of revelations had a lot of
cool imagery in it and cool stuff but it
was it was just a prophecy that didn't
happen
although it was um real interesting it
had a lot of numerology in it there's a
lot of symbolism that kind of
eludes the modern person but back then
people would have known what you were
talking about
yeah that's what i'm saying they're
talking about memes basically memes of
the day
you know for like all you pepe
[ __ ] i see a frog before me
egyptian and keck
i mean you know you would know what that
was but ten thousand years ago
or ten thousand years from now or two
thousand years from now people have no
idea you're talking about a [ __ ] frog
and cac and chatelay and weird [ __ ] like
that like those people
but the early christians were like that
they used their own terminology
but that's what everyone does right and
they were talking about
the number of the beast is 666 or 603
score and six
there's another one that might have been
616 depending on which
edition but you most people believe it's
666. and uh
what you could do is if you were to in
um what are you doing poke she keeps
like coming up and scratching the chair
i remember which which uh i don't
remember if it was in greek or
i think it was in greek if
it's in greek or in latin one of the two
each
each letter had a numerical value
so what it's saying is is if you add up
the numbers of the man's name it adds up
to six hundred and they were different
in numerology
big end of that the numbers of things
like seven or
not only seven but seven fold and seven
or
seventy seven fold that mean oh [ __ ]
77 fold oh [ __ ] you know
that's big you know like you know let
him not be
avenged sevenfold but 77
fold oh hell yeah i know that oh my god
i'm not gonna [ __ ] you up seven times
seventy seven
times man to the 77th power i'm gonna
kick you in the back
seven destruction all right
no one no one wants to hear that right
but if you
um take the word neuron caesar
nero caesar caesar caesar nero caesar or
nero caesar's
or caesar nero depending on what
language
it'll add up to 666 which is the emperor
that they seem to be talking about at
the time of the writing so they're
saying that
nero is the antichrist he's an
anti-christian person trying to wipe out
the christians he's trying to cancel us
this is cancelled culture
this is they're like because they were
talking about contemporary stuff
that was going on the ancient
world and ancient people were just like
us they just didn't have the same medium
but the thinking was very much the same
sure and they had a lot of the same
cultural
phenomenon going on at the time
especially in rome
so they're talking about nero
all right they're saying nero's just
gonna destroy the christians
now who are the christians they're
talking about they're talking about a
very small
cult in rome this is not a bit which to
them it must have seemed like that
yeah but they didn't have the benefit of
2 000 years of hindsight
yeah so you're talking about some this
is a book
written for a very small audience a long
time ago
and um there were lots of little small
cults
a long time ago this just happens to be
one that survived see this is like the
equivalent
right of if one of my books which hardly
anybody has read
yeah 2 000 years from now it was like
the only book that survived somehow
um she would be considered the greatest
author of the american right and then
like that was like a bible and then like
people like made a whole religion
right out of one of my stories which
would be super [ __ ] weird right but
it was like pretty much the same thing
though
i mean pretty much the same right and um
from mostly what you can put together
and these are guys like dr robert
and price we've had him on this show
before and i still listen to him and
they got a new one called the christ
myth podcast is really good yeah he's
still around
they're still around he's on a much
better show he's almost a young guy who
actually has all the technological
skills to constantly stream him and have
all these guys
it's called i think it's called myth
vision
and uh that he he's a real good young
dude and he's bringing together all
these [ __ ] great
minds from who are religious scholars
and showcasing their work it's the first
time that has ever happened in human
history
the internet is a powerful [ __ ]
research tool
you can get all these guys from around
the world to have all these specialties
and get them together in a scene and
make progress back in the 1700s did it
take a hundred years to do the work that
they've done
with like written letters just written
letters for this it would take a hundred
years
like go over by ship right exactly [ __ ]
now you can get the greatest minds
together and they can compare notes and
get put together
what had happened what the [ __ ] are they
talking about
and uh they pretty much figured it out
there's it can only be a couple of
different things
depending on what the subject is like
what is it is she
doing poke cannot dig through books
she's trying to dig
you can't dig through a book there might
be something good on the other side of
these yeah
that's not a door
[Laughter]
that's right and she runs like oh i
didn't do it that's all right she well
she's pretty that's right
she's going to come over right yeah but
pay attention yeah but do something
yeah i forgot where i was i was just
talking about um
how much their uh how much progress
they've made in a very short amount of
time of
just experts in this form of literature
because it is it's literature yeah uh
comparing notes and figuring out what
story came from where and
and how old what is older than what you
know i mean
you have to put all this stuff together
and find out where the source is
so and how many original stories were
there and when was this
see i love that kind of [ __ ] yeah and
honestly i kind of feel like i know
i know there's like a segment of people
that are just kind of like
well and there's always a segment of
people that are like this every
generation
that are like oh you know the sky is
falling the world is going to [ __ ] it's
like the internet's the worst thing ever
social media is the worst thing ever but
it's like that's
i don't know i feel like that's a really
limiting because to me
it seems like the internet has like
opened up oh it's great great invention
holy [ __ ] man
it's like i'm doing [ __ ] now that
i would like i really wanted to do like
back in the 80s but it's like i didn't
even like imagine that there would ever
be like a framework to do that
it's a great technology but with all
great technologies it can be used for
even well there's always going to be a
downside i mean that's just kind of how
[ __ ] goes
you just have to deal with it the main
thing is to try to prevent
big companies from taking over the
internet
or or big governments see governments
can't do it themselves they'll get
blamed so they hire companies to do it
in their name or do it for them like
they're mercenary contractors so you
trace it back to governments or ruling
classes
trying to control the narrative on the
internet by by
channeling you
down certain algorithmic [ __ ]
rabbit holes to get you to come to a
conclusion that isn't true
you have to have a free internet just
like you need a free press
um there's a lot of [ __ ] shenanigans
going on
and a lot of it coming out of silicon
valley and a lot of it coming out of
china china has its own version of
silicon valley their great wall of china
and all their [ __ ]
all sensor algorithms you need the old
internet kind of like the old internet
of the 90s
where you could avoid bad [ __ ] but you
could find all the good [ __ ] you needed
you didn't have anybody [ __ ] trying
to brainwash you through [ __ ]
algorithms
i mean they had that damn guy go before
the senate
who knew all about it and knew all about
this computer science and psychology he
said
you can reprogram people to believe in
things that are not true
through this just by just by channeling
them down a certain direction and only
showing them
certain things you know and absolutely
true
you have to have a free internet
if not some [ __ ] going to try
to dictate to you what reality is well
the thing is
well the weird thing about it is that a
lot of it is not even human controlled
anymore because it's all like an
algorithm and it's not necessarily
sinister because what they're doing is
they're trying to see what is this
person
interested in buying i'm what are they
buying i'm going to show them more of
that
that's partly it but also some of it is
it
is nefarious because yeah i'm not saying
that i'm just saying that
in there you can hire companies to to
[ __ ] with your algorithms to
show you things to push you down
directions
uh that that aren't true you know in
other words it's just another form of
propaganda
you know it's here the thing is though
is look me and jenny's
generation are actually pretty resistant
to propaganda
i mean well it's old school propaganda
was very obvious
by the time the 80s had rolled around
they got a lot better and
90s propaganda was [ __ ] really slick
but i knew this [ __ ] was propaganda when
i saw it
but i think people growing up i think i
think
i think people think what do you call
them the people that are now in their
20s and
30s are not quite as resistant to
propaganda as we were oh i don't know
about that they may be more but well
because i kind of feel like
well the thing about it i kind of feel
like even though it sucked at the time
i'm kind of glad that i grew up poor
because growing up poor you
can't in a lot of ways you're resistant
to people trying to sell you [ __ ]
because you can't afford it
yeah so it's kind of like people coming
at you it's like hey i have this that'll
make your life better and it's just cost
49.99 it's like i don't have that money
so it's just kind of like you learn to
tune all that [ __ ] out because it's like
look i can't afford that anyway so [ __ ]
off oracle mom
says uh gen xers are protected by our
cynicism
i absolutely agree very cynical yeah
and honestly it's it's not like
i don't know i kind of feel like we
gotta we're kind of like the forgotten
generation i guess
yeah but in a way though the cynicism
it's bad in some ways because you're
kind of like ready to like [ __ ] on
everything but in a way it's good
because
you're kind of like isn't always
[ __ ] off it's not
well no but i'm just saying there's
another side to it which is good because
you're just kind of like you don't
believe anybody's [ __ ] on
face value yeah which is a good thing
every time something is presented to you
you must ask
yourself the question ki bono
who does this benefit who benefits who
benefits from this
and it will in that usually unveils
what this is that that that even
includes news
because news media they
curate their news they're showing you
the events that they want you to see
for some reason or another you have to
ask yourself who's benefiting from this
well usually the person who's betting
affinity from it is the one who's paid
for it
that blew my mind back in [ __ ] the
early 2000s
when i found out that saudi oil
potentates
could buy positive press
on cnn if you've got money you can buy
anything yeah
blew my [ __ ] mind cnn with that
it was james earl jones you know cnn and
we we grew up cnn was a 24-hour news
channel
had a little ticker tape underneath
there they'd show you all this weird
[ __ ] i started to get real
suspicious during that first gulf war
when those dudes were faking gas attacks
and throwing their
and we we'd be in the barracks watching
that [ __ ] laughing going
man they just faked a damn gas attack
and then you could see how they damn
i don't know you guys weren't there it
didn't
they were ramp they were just trying to
make new war footage
every [ __ ] day on cnn well like i
said they're just
they want it's just like nowadays they
want they want clicks they want clicks
they want money
for money so anything that's going to
lead to more people clicking on the [ __ ]
whether it's outrage whether it's drama
whether it's anything
that was 1990 that's what they're going
to do that's well
they are understanding yeah humans are
not different
than they were thousands of years ago we
love drama 1991
we love being outraged yeah shit's gonna
make you mad she's gonna do this
they totally know that so that's why but
see
i know that they know that so i don't
click on anything like that because
i don't care i don't care this was 1991
and i remember them faking it
faking that they were had survived a gas
attack the two news reporters
and you could find that [ __ ] on on
youtube probably in a way honestly i
think it's like really funny because
sometimes if i'm reading an article and
then like i'll see some like ad at the
bottom
like that you know people don't want you
to know about this i'm just like yep i
don't want to know about it bye
it's like it's like so obvious but i saw
that they're i saw that and i was a kid
and i was in the army at the time and
[ __ ] i was just like
man they they will fake a news [ __ ]
report and that kind of
was weird but it kind of like ran off me
like a [ __ ]
off the back like with water running off
a duck's back
i kind of forgot that they did that and
then a few years later
it turned out that they that cnn got
caught this isn't the cnn
of today this is the cnn of the [ __ ]
early 2000s
would during the second gulf war that
saudi oil prince
saudi princesses prince asadi pritz
have bought a whole bunch of positive pr
in on cnn you could just pay them to
write a good story about you
it didn't really it's nothing nefarious
i mean nothing well now
he [ __ ] had had them
report how good how good he was it's an
infomercial
like an info worship and that [ __ ]
blew my mind
and you can just first that's why you
can go on if you have a youtube channel
that has over 10 000 subscribers which
ours does
you can go on sites like grapevine you
go on sites like that
and there's like others companies that
want you
to make a video integrated like how much
you love their [ __ ]
um and they'll pay you like x amount of
dollars so you'll send they'll send you
free [ __ ] or whatever
and it's like you know a lot of
instagram people a lot of like tick-tock
people like make a living doing this
kind of stuff because that's just
i mean you know that's just the hustle
man that's it's always been like that
like i said even back to like people
[ __ ] about it nowadays but that's been
going on since like
forever it's been like the early days of
newspapers seriously i read a couple
books
about remember back in the old days when
newspapers were like the main
media and uh you know most big cities
had several competing ones
holy [ __ ] if you like read about the
stuff if they couldn't get
the scoop on the other paper they would
just like pull [ __ ] out their ass they
would just like make stuff up
yeah and print it and the more salacious
the better so it's like
even back then and this i'm talking
about victorian era
even back then they knew what people's
psychology was oh this is going to get
if it bleeds it leads
everybody knows that victor goes way to
hear about yellow journalism no i know
all about yellow jewelry that's what i
mean
so the thing is though is that when i
was going to [ __ ]
going through school they would teach
about yellow
journalism but then they would kind of
like make you believe that that was
something from the past they don't do
that anymore
oh hell yeah they do that [ __ ] they're
doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] like crazy like
i said because it works
it works and then it works and then uh
xanada says yeah remember when they had
that
girl the ambassador's daughter lie about
the iraqi soldiers taking the babies off
the incubators yeah i remember i
believed that at the time
i did not i believed it i [ __ ]
believed it
yeah i bet they did take their babies
off those incubators it was all a
[ __ ] lie
to help get us in that damn war because
so much money was changing hands behind
the scenes yeah like i said
always it's always [ __ ] mine
like you said who benefits yeah that's
what i mean
yeah gramps is now talking about the
videos of the cnn reporters getting
blown over by the [ __ ] hurricane and
then people just walk behind them yeah
yeah
or yeah yeah i'm sorry are there in the
boat paddling the flood has happened
then somebody just walks behind its
ankle deep
well see well in florida like i said i
grew up in florida
so we're almost we're like ignored to
like the
the over-the-top hurricane coverage
honestly i don't watch the hurricane
coverage if a hurricane's coming i just
want to say look where's the map
i don't want to watch like they send
some like poor schlub out there to like
stand in the rain
and like be like yeah this is and then
like pretend that they're being blown
away or whatever it's just like i
you know i'm over that but they still do
it though
um but but they've been doing that since
i was a kid
my advice to y'all youngsters at 52
my advice to y'all youngsters they got a
bunch of old [ __ ] and they're
listening to me too don't believe
anything that
[ __ ] say well if it seems i'm
just saying i'm just saying don't
believe
you know don't don't believe anything
but if it seems
way over the top or if it seems like way
worse or way better
than you think like real life is a paid
average then probably
your probably your instincts are correct
i'm not saying that it's like you can't
believe anything i'm not saying that
but and they'll shut well some of the
[ __ ] they show you yeah that happened
but then there's all the [ __ ] they won't
show you too they're curating
yeah that's what i'm saying there might
be some [ __ ] they left the money
involved of what they're gonna show you
they're being hired to [ __ ] sell a
certain narrative
right that's all it is that's all you
just have to be aware of that that's all
that's all and like i said i don't i
don't disbelieve
everything i see because you know then
you'd just be like a [ __ ] nihilist
and you wouldn't believe in anything but
if i always feel like if every if
anything is like
yeah if anything is like way more
[ __ ] up or way more dramatic or oh my
god it's the end of the world if
anything is like over dramatic
i just i'm not buying that um
that's one thing because everybody wants
you know everybody wants people to click
on your [ __ ] so it's like oh we have to
make this seem like the worst thing ever
or the best thing ever
so if you're trying to make [ __ ] sound
like the worst thing ever the best thing
ever i
i'm not interested because i know that
you're trying to [ __ ] me
so um yeah grandpa's hammer says how
come google knows what i'm about to
search for before i'm typing
that's because one they have algorithms
that know
what you like because like i said i'm
usually searching for horror movies and
true crime
so if i start typing something along
those lines it'll fill it in because
they're like oh this is a horror and
true crime person
so we're going to help and usually
they're correct so you know it's creepy
but whatever it's helpful
also they're going by popularity of what
everybody is searching for
like i said it's maybe it's like a
little nefarious it doesn't bother me
all that much because i'm not like
looking for anything
bad so in a way it's kind of helpful
that it's like i just put in a couple
letters and it's like oh hey they know
i'm talking about that horror movie
because i've searched for a million
horror movies before
so that's cool but you know i'm not
all that bothered by it i don't know i
know people are but i'm not all that
bothered um
you know uh xanada says yeah you can
turn off
save search and predictive search yeah
i'm gonna like i said i'm not bothered
by it because i'm not looking for
you know i'm not looking for anything
that's like [ __ ] you know that would
get me flagged on anything
mostly the [ __ ] i'm the [ __ ] i'm
searching for is usually like true crime
cases
horror movies that kind of crap so
the fact that google knows that i search
for those kind of things so those are
the first things that come up in the
search that does not bother me one bit
and it just makes my life easier so i
don't really care
i mean i can say they're keeping [ __ ]
tabs on all of us every one of us but
here's the thing there's so much
information about everybody is that
that's what i'm saying
if you ever did anything and they wanted
to investigate you afterwards they
didn't pull up a [ __ ]
file and they'd sell that [ __ ] to the
[ __ ] fbi
and they'd be able to put together a
whole [ __ ] pros yeah but like i said
i can't worry about it
i mean there's there's billions of
people in the world when you look at how
[ __ ] shit's going
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do they
can't even keep a [ __ ] city safe
well that's what i'm saying i'm kidding
about it like like i said i think people
are too worried about
some them out there like some big
like some small cabal of like and they
know everything and they can do
everything like look no it's a bunch of
everything is just a bunch of dumbasses
like me and him
um who [ __ ] up at their jobs and who's
just like a bunch of regular [ __ ] i
was telling i was telling that
it's like don't worry about it i was
telling that to zen don't worry about it
senator the other day is worried about
this and that and the fbi and they're
doing this
there's no big like massive intelligence
or anything it's nothing like well there
is but they just
they can't do everything at once that's
what i mean it's a but it's
it's a bunch of people and they're
idiots yeah they're idiots
so i'm not really worried about it if
you've ever worked in that environment
you when you're working at state or
federal level or anything you know
having to do with law enforcement or
military it's a cluster [ __ ] it's a
serious cluster that's what i'm saying
they're not men for men dollar for
dollar
they are not effective um
mostly what you hear these politicians
say
in these on the news is [ __ ] [ __ ]
they don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about this is nobody does it's
like
theater and most of the [ __ ] that they
[ __ ] say
can never translate down to the ground
it never actually
affects the girl that's what i'm saying
so i don't understand why people worry
so much about it they're mostly saying
this [ __ ] to their peers
and to look good for the news cycle and
and to their political party that
they're in for that day
you're you can't read in too much into
it because
they don't know what they're [ __ ]
saying and they're they're making that
[ __ ] up as they go along mostly
here's the thing i kind of feel like
maybe this is because i was brought
up um you know my mom my grandpa
everybody like that
and you know like i said i grew up in
kind of quote unquote gifted programs
whatever
my grandpa always taught me look if some
other [ __ ] learned to do
something you can learn to
do it too most people are idiots don't
worry about it so it's kind of like it's
that kind of thing i've worked in like
corporate situations i've worked in all
that kind of stuff
most people if they're just doing their
[ __ ] job and they're going home
they're worried about their family just
like you are
it's just like nobody there's no super
genius there's no mastermind there's no
nothing like that it's not centralized
enough
that's what i'm saying and it's like
that's why i'm not a big fan of like all
these stupid conspiracy theories and all
that kind of crap it's like look
you know i'm a smart person i consider
myself a smart person and it's like most
people
are really are as smart as me or maybe
not as much
so it's kind of like i'm not really
worried about
and honestly you get two or three people
in a room and they try to figure out how
to do something and they're not going to
agree on anything and it's just going to
be like a big [ __ ] show
so i'm like dude i've worked on like
projects where it was just me and one
other person and we couldn't like agree
on [ __ ]
so no no one has a big master plan for
anything well nobody it depends uh no
not true
[ __ ] there are all kinds of okay well
even if they do
it's not going to work out the way they
think there you go no plan making that's
what i'm saying
no plan makes contact with [ __ ]
reality that's what i'm saying uh but no
there are people that have [ __ ] big
master plans well sure but
that doesn't mean anything just ask a
mexican drug cartel
all their [ __ ] is planned out they know
exactly how their business is running
here's the thing don't give government
agencies so much weight
they're not that competent that's why
exactly that's why that's exactly let me
finish what i'm saying
that's why they subcontract most of
their work out
to private security companies and
private corporations do a
lot of a lot of the war they call it a
war
a lot of [ __ ] that was happening in
afghanistan wasn't really even being
done by the us military is being done by
[ __ ] private contractors
most of them little old ladies piloting
drones
which you don't think of that but that's
that's really what it is
they got private security companies that
just
filled with little old friendly old
ladies here in the united states
flying drones around blowing up [ __ ]
people
here come on go blow up yeah person yeah
you know what i mean and she oh well
that was a good one
oh boom
don't for one second i think there's any
of these double 07 [ __ ] james bond
[ __ ] spies running around but that
yes they've all been replaced that's
fantasy yeah they have all those there's
no reason
to have a guy like that because what
he's doing can all be
found on the internet through people's
[ __ ] little tracks that they left
behind
all all intelligence we're in a totally
different era
all in intel about people and
organizations can be just extracted
through people's data
fingerprints so what you really have is
ai programs and private companies
that have the ability to go in there and
find out where somebody is
um they can do that but there's no james
bonds and [ __ ]
i mean they might send delta down there
to go get the guy once they find him
that's how they found bin laden but
that's very high priority targets yeah
can i just say
they're not gonna if you sitting in your
[ __ ] little trailer down in arizona
okay worried because you voted for trump
that they're gonna come get you
they don't have time for your [ __ ] about
you no they're seriously
they don't it's too much money there's
too many there's 10 million at least 10
million people that did that
[ __ ] they don't have the ability to
do anything to you no one cares
i just kind of feel like people and i do
this is a very human thing
everybody is the star of their own movie
i get that
but in the great scheme of things there
are billions of people on the earth
there are what 400 million people in the
united states alone
um if you're not doing any [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
like that's going to cost a lot of
people a lot of money
no one gives a crap what you're doing
all right honestly
and now me and him went to high school
together and we both know each other's
it says i have a federal it decide he
was he goes ah you read it you read it
grab your sister says i was a federal
agent for years
he's going to tell you i was a fit agent
for years trust me when i say the
government is too incompetent to
maintain massive files on people exactly
no one cares unless like i said unless
you were doing something
super [ __ ] up that is causing a lot of
people to lose a lot of money
you have to be a no serious one nobody
cares about you nobody cares if you're
growing pot in your backyard no nobody
cares
nobody cares you don't have to be
[ __ ] paranoid you know
nothing no one's gonna find you it's
fine but most
times most when you find out in the
military if you do military government
service
most of leadership qualities
is a man or woman's ability to emanate
leadership charisma which is a feeling
that you're in control they're not
really in control
really but you can get a good feeling
that that well that person's in control
they're in charge everything's taken
care of it's the alpha dog
feeling the dog pack is [ __ ] calm
when the alpha dog is secure and the
alpha dog's got it all under control
yeah
he's under control he's got everything's
safe but
really he's just got an office he issues
orders whether or not those orders are
actually followed if they actually make
an impact
probably not it's mostly feelings
and yeah that's what you're seeing with
these politicians they're trying to
exude
feelings to their audience and uh
do i think that it's helpful no it's
destructive
they're all incompetent they're all
[ __ ] baboons but
everybody is just a person that's what
i'm saying so that's what i'm saying so
don't
get right i kind of feel like there's
this is why i worry about your own
narrow ass
and the people that in your family your
family and the things that are around
you
and your local community you can't my
home control some [ __ ] this has my whole
philosophy of life and maybe like i know
because sometimes you said like i seem
apathetic and stuff like that i'm not
apathetic
it's just that i understand that
no one's really in control of [ __ ] uh a
lot of [ __ ] is random that happens
and people pretending that they're
people pretend that they're in control
and it's like they're not um i know it
makes them feel better but fine
i you know i'm i'm very i've become very
zen with the fact
that we don't really have a lot of
control over what happens
not in the big picture in the big
picture and that's fine
um it's you know it's scary but it's
fine i'm you know i've
come to terms with it so it's like no
one's in control of the [ __ ]
no one really knows what's going on
everyone's just as stupid
uh and ignorant as i am and doesn't know
what's going on so it's all fine
um maybe some people know a little bit
more
but that's okay so i'm just it it's fine
everything will work out the way it's
gonna work out there's not a lot you can
do about it
just chill just chill out be happy in my
experience
all right in my experience the only
things you can do
is protect your friends and family and
the things that you care about
the things in your local sphere
and here in florida the biggest threat
to me here in florida is a hurricane
hurricane yeah we're worried about
nature yeah honestly
hurricane nature will kick my ass what
would a hurricane
be a good-sized hurricane would be like
katrina
been through that which means prolonged
power outage
yeah that means prolonged
inability to resupply so you're going to
need food
storable food potable water
[ __ ] that can be water because it could
be collected and filtered
and because worst case will be two
months i think two months
worst case because katrina was about two
months
all right and i don't think it'd get
much worse than that so food
water defense because you couldn't call
the cops so you better have a way to
defend your family
and your property if everybody does that
things stay
calm because all your neighbors are
doing the same thing
and in florida most of your neighbors
know about this
yeah one thing i found in florida like i
said i i was born here i grew up here my
whole life
i've been through i haven't been through
anything as bad as katrina but i've been
through a lot of hurricanes tornadoes
[ __ ] like that
so it's kind of like most of the time
most of your neighbors are totally cool
and
everyone is gonna like help everyone
else out right in your neighborhood
so it's gonna be fine it'll be fine yeah
now so you got food
water power defense
all right the only thing would be
another thing would be communications if
you have power
very difficult to communicate through
the internet
or if the internet is down or if you
don't have a generator
another thing you might want to look at
is something like a radio
they got a lot of little radios for like
200 bucks that can pick up
ham a little small handheld hat and
you'll be able to [ __ ] hear that
that's a good thing and they're all yeah
that's this next thing on my list is to
get some good
good little ham radio or a little little
kind of survival this type radial might
be
uh there's a couple different things
there's ham and then there's [ __ ] uh
what's that other one
gmrs i think is what it's called and you
can pick up all your
government stations for security
[ __ ] emergency stuff and you can
transmit up to about five miles
with that probably more like two um
but you don't really need to transmit
it's
you need to be able to monitor that's
the most important thing well yeah you
just want to know what you're going to
want to know what's going on on the
emergency
frequencies um you used to be able to
get police scanners but i think they're
all encrypted now
so you probably would not be able to
break police encryption
uh which is funny because my dad used to
like listen up yeah
all the time let's go see the accident
that's the main thing
so power you want to get a good
generator
i got two generators a good gener good
honda and another one that's even bigger
that'll run the whole house all the
refrigerators and the
central air because those are kind of
like you don't want all your food to go
bad and you don't want to like sweat
your balls just plug it into the side of
the house and it'll [ __ ] ride the
whole house
just gotta stock possum gasoline for the
[ __ ] hurricane season
well it is hurricane season it's
hurricane season until november
right 30th and it won't be until next
month we can get that [ __ ] connector
on the side of the damn house
but in an emergency we can run the
little well september and october are
the worst months if
you think about preparing for a
hurricane
if you prepared for everything like a
hurricane you probably pretty much
survive anything
if you had riots breaking out civil
unrest and all this kind of [ __ ] you see
on the news happening up north if you
plan for it like it was a riot or
like like a hurricane you'd be all right
because you never think
like i said i was i was born here so
it's just kind of like every year
that was just something that you did
yeah it's like oh we got to get the
water
we got to get the plywood we got to get
this that and the other thing it's like
every year you would kind of like go
through this whole
[ __ ] because you didn't know if i mean
we were mostly lucky
i grew up in daytona which is right on
the coast but most
hurricanes would either like go across
south florida and then go into the gulf
of mexico or they'd like
glance us and then keep going up the
coast so it's like we got hit by a bunch
but none of them were super super
terrible
um i remember going through a few like i
remember going through one in 1979 that
was pretty shitty
and then there was one in uh or actually
there were four
in 2005 2006 something like that
that um there were four of them within
a six-week period that blew uh our power
was out for a very long time
our street flooded um some of my [ __ ]
roof tiles blew off because i owned a
house back then
um my whole fence blew down so i had to
replace that which blew
um but the house was still there because
it was built in the 50s and it was made
of concrete black
so that was good but honestly
if you so i don't know i'm just like
because i'm
i grew up in that environment where like
every year like all your [ __ ] could be
blown away
yeah so it's kind of like blase at this
point wait
wait i grew way i grew up [ __ ] if
you'd show me all this prepper [ __ ]
i'd have [ __ ] laughed at that until i
[ __ ] went through katrina
that's when i was like yeah now i
understand it
and i think katrina actually gave my
generation a big [ __ ] wake up
everybody around the [ __ ] world saw
that and the country saw that the united
states
and that was when all these [ __ ]
prepper [ __ ] shows appeared out of
nowhere
and then whole companies that would sell
you the big number 10. because you could
see that it you could
have it these big number 10 cans of
freeze-dried
food and stuff yeah freeze-dried like
astronaut type food just add water and
you got a whole bunch of food
all that [ __ ] would have come in real
handy to a whole hell of a lot of people
in katrina
and i mean the thing about it like i
said there's it's scary
but in florida it's like it's an annual
and it's long it comes like hurricane
season starts
june 1st and it goes till november 30th
uh the worst is usually september
october
yeah that's like um but you can have
some before then but usually september
october is like the worst era
it's like a damn f train and so
so i'm pretty aware every year you would
get oh [ __ ] oh here comes this one and
here's and my grandma was like super
paranoid about them so it's like
freak out yeah so it's like she always
had the weather channel on if one was
like coming toward us
and you know and the news would like
hump it up to you know pump it up too
because they're kind of like oh here it
comes and it's like so it'd be like a
week or
whatever and you'd be like worried about
it but it's like you worry about [ __ ]
every year
for your whole life you kind of get
so i know that like a lot of floridians
that were born here
like a big hurricane is coming and
they're just like whatevs
i got like [ __ ] plywood on my windows
i got a big [ __ ] bucket of candy i'm
fine
i got my grill you know but that's why
because we've
you know i'm from here so it's like
every single year
you have that [ __ ] happening and it's
like it could happen it has happened
look at [ __ ] what happened in
homestead [ __ ] all that that place
was like torn to [ __ ] pieces
so we've seen it happen if we're not
apathetic about it
we've seen what can happen but it's just
kind of like every year
we're just kind of like well we can't
you can't do anything about it you can't
stop it
it's nature yeah so it's gonna [ __ ] you
the uh so you so you just kind of have
to like
let it ride yeah you know what i mean so
it's i've kind of become it's scary but
i'm kind of zen about it
yeah i mean we did have a thing camp guy
says he's hoarding stuff like crazy
so i don't know so you know remember
that one we had like
a couple years ago when we had that one
hit like that sort of glanced off us
and it got so bad that we were like yeah
i don't really want to sleep in the
bedroom anymore because we have a
sliding glass window and i said if that
blows in like with the glass that's
going to like not be good
so we went and we took pokey into the
closet
and we shut the pocket door and just
slept in the closet with pookie
yeah grandfather's hammer says he's a
ham operator he gives us call sign
k-e-a-n-o-n um
again uh jariah
trick punk says he has three shortwave
radios he needs a ham though
yeah a lot of people are into that [ __ ]
i mean any kind of like battery but
it's just good to have like for anything
like i said just if bad weather
is probably like a more likely scenario
especially if you're in the south
grandparent says police frequencies are
all digital trunk systems now scanners
exist but they call 500
they cost 500. hit me up on youtube man
i want to see what it would take to get
on
to to scam police later on you got my
direct it's funny because everybody used
to do that i would like to scan it
because remember back in the old days my
dad used to have like a police scanner
like on the [ __ ] dashboard of the car
so he could like avoid so he could speed
and like so people wouldn't pull him
over
yeah because i feel like that was kind
of thing so i guess like cops got mad
about mom for nick says problem is up
north the tools you need to survive a
riot are illegal
in my opinion bro you do what you have
to do don't worry about other people
tell you what to do
you do what you have to do okay
they're not following rules half this
[ __ ] isn't following rules
just keep just keep your [ __ ] low
senator said i heard people went missing
in katrina they're still on again
exactly a lot of people like 20 000 of
them are still missing
well a lot of them just probably got
washed away into the [ __ ] ocean
yeah sadly and then they will probably
never find them
and there was a lot of [ __ ] um young
young black females vanished very
strange
there was a gang of guys that were
snatching them off of [ __ ]
torches too you see when the
stop it poop when the power went out the
air conditioning went out it was [ __ ]
miserably hot
so people were sleeping on their porches
in certain areas
she's pulling on my makeup yeah people
were sleeping on their porches
and uh in the middle of the night there
was a couple of occasions
that we heard of through the state
police that four or five guys would run
up and grab some young girl and then run
off with her in front of her family just
it happened and you know they couldn't
stop them they all had guns and stuff
and the girl never seen again so
evidently raped and murdered
down in the damn hood
well yeah i mean if you were uh of that
uh proclivity then that would be
that'd be a good tradition too they were
stealing everything they were [ __ ]
a lot of payback guys that had beefs
with other dudes
prior to that it was a good time to
commit a murder on your enemies
it was just uh it was a time of [ __ ]
chaos
civilization just vanished after about
two days gone
camp guys said it's almost 80 inside my
house right now only been hot the last
week or 10 days oh well
man in a way you're kind of lucky uh
it's been hot here since
what april yeah um you know
not inside the house because we keep our
ac pretty low
although honestly you said i didn't i
didn't
feel this but you said it was hot in the
house the other day and then you went
out and the ac was like blocked with
moss or something it happens like every
year
every year the drain tube that comes the
ac
gets like clogged up it gets clogged
with [ __ ] uh maw
not moss what do you call it like slime
like uh it's like slime mold
yeah and you have to [ __ ] open up
those little place of port and you blast
it out of there with a high pressure
water hose
and you get the flow going you run out
there and you see it's just like
there's probably about 10 feet like 10
feet of
white slime yeah came out and then it
started dripping
even in florida you would think that
somebody
would have designed a better air
conditioning unit
um maybe someone did but i i kind of
feel like people that are building
houses are not
putting them in there they're just
working fast yeah so i kind of feel like
every year every year when i grew up
it seemed like every year the air
conditioner would break yeah
because it's just it's too hot like the
air conditioning unit can't
sheila says i know that deal with it
sheila said i know after hurricane sandy
dudes are stealing the generators that
are running outside the garages here
yeah you got to do that
uh what you do is when you put your
generator outside you have to chain it
to something
so they can't run off with it got to
chain it to a tree or something
well we did that didn't we we did we ran
the geneva generator
we had we had security here it's hard
for them to get in
yeah we live in like a gated yeah it's
harder you don't really unless it's one
of your neighbors which is possible
but you know and this neighborhood is is
not a desperate neighborhood [ __ ]
everybody was [ __ ] running their
generators
so everybody's prepared yeah a lot of
people had generated yeah that's
neighborhood
this is yeah the the neighborhood
generators one of them [ __ ] an
emergency i can trade it's brand new
only been used once
it's just not it doesn't crank up it's a
honda too it just doesn't it's a honda
black max
it's [ __ ] nice it's just that it's
not enough to run the entire house and
the central air system and that's what i
wanted
i wanted something to run all my
refrigerators the internet and the
central airs
and because that's kind of all you need
yeah yeah that way i go i don't give a
[ __ ] about
[ __ ] i'm still in civilization like
nothing happened i got all my food in
the fridge
i got the ac running and i've still got
what i still got wi-fi
yeah that's all you need really i can't
really think of anything else
because we've been without or nearly
without
i had that old generator running out
there
we had problems well honestly i think as
long as we've lived in this house
the longest we've been without power was
what two days
two days yeah and she was [ __ ] happy
and that sucked enough now
like i said back in 2004 2005 when we
had like those four
uh hurricanes or tropical storms or
whatever hit within six weeks
uh at the house that i used to own
my power was out for eight days
yeah uh that sucked a lot
a lot and also my street was flooded so
i couldn't get out
can't stop talking about good portable
ac units
you know oh and the ac at my work was
out too and i still had to go to work
and my street was flooded and the ac at
work was out i got so that was special i
got three
window units and then another stand-in
unit that [ __ ]
exhausts out it doesn't work too well
that's what i was running
that last storm but all that's obsolete
now
because i can run a central system off
that one generator
so i got a bunch of [ __ ] window units
that might be able to [ __ ] sell when
i think about it
true yeah i don't have to run i wouldn't
have to run extension cord all
throughout the house either
yeah because that kind of blew there was
like extension cords all over the
[ __ ] house
it looked so bad and even with that it
was kind of like the house was still
like
stunk like a wet dog yeah because you
can't air condition the whole house just
rooms
yeah well i think well yeah we just
air-conditioned like the bedroom
yeah and like the bedrooms yeah that was
pretty much it
office in here yeah and then like the
cats are like what the [ __ ]
because the living rooms are all in the
living rooms and the dining rooms
stay yeah yeah they were like
what are you even doing cats are spoiled
you open the door and they're like oh
it's too hot that's what like she gets
all excited
because she's in the ac like all day
she's sleeping
then when night comes she's like ooh i
want to go outside and she's like start
scratching at the window
and then like we're like okay well we
put a little collar on
we open the door and then she looks out
and then she get and then her little
back arch she's like
this is oh
and then she runs to the front door like
that outside is gonna be different like
each outside is a different temperature
let me check the front let me check the
front no that one too this one sucks too
this one sucks too she's trying to go
out and she's trying to go out there too
look
she thinks that closet doors she thinks
that she still thinks that
oh poor pokey she still thinks that the
closet
leads to outside she goes in there like
i leave that open a little bit
for her to like go in there and play i
don't know what she's doing in there
she goes in there
she says she goes in there and then all
of a sudden
like five minutes later i hear
oh it was bored i don't know what she's
doing in there she's like i don't like
it in there
that wasn't what i that wasn't when i
bought it
oh pokey it's not outside i've told you
that a million times
stop it
she's so crazy she honestly we saw her
today
she has decided i don't know if you guys
know but we have that um
that kind of like what do you call it
like it's it's like a cat
system uh that's like mounted on the
walls
like out in the foyer or whatever and so
there's like
damn poop so you like it there's like
little things that they can jump on and
like a little egg thing they can like
lay in uh and there's like little
hammock things that they can sleep in
now pookie was not real big on them it's
like sometimes she'll go in the egg
thing and like sleep in there
but not much beijing loved it though
like she would go up in the hammock like
by the ceiling and she would sleep in
there and that was kind of her thing
but the last couple times that i walked
past there i saw that pookie
was up in the hammock by the ceiling
so she must have like taken the [ __ ]
over from beige
and beijing is probably not happy about
it
terry in there said that the the [ __ ]
cheapest ac unit is just a [ __ ] fan
and a block of ice
in florida that that would be really
really doesn't work that wouldn't even
put a dent
it really doesn't work i mean down here
like i said i know everybody says it's
not the heat it's the humidity but
that's totally true that's the humidity
being in florida in the summer feels
like if somebody
soaked a big thick towel in hot water
and just like laid it on your face and
you couldn't like
take it off your face and then like but
that's like
going outside feels like that it feels
like somebody just put a wet towel on
your face that you can't
take off so like everything
is sticky even if you live even if
you're in
air conditioning which we are you get
out of the shower
and it's just like you're still sticky
you feel you still feel sticky and
sweaty
and you just can't ever get rid of that
feeling for like months and months at a
time
it's miserable it's a miserable
environment
ac makes it tolerable but it's still not
it's not ideal i don't care about it
it's not ideal
jenny's sick of it but she doesn't know
how good she's spoiled
she doesn't know how good [ __ ] i was
born here yes don't talk to me about
like
[ __ ] florida's [ __ ] pretty cool i
like it i like
yeah it is [ __ ] humid but and the
bugs
yeah it's not even like you got to lean
into it so you just lean into the [ __ ]
yeah it's humid i'm gonna go to the pool
that's that's that's how you eat well
you have to
like there's no honestly like i said i
was in
when i was on vacation i was in st
augustine and i went to
the alligator farm and i was like look i
know i'm going to be here like all day
i'm going to be outside most of the day
so i'm just going to have to deal with
it was like [ __ ] 500 degrees i don't
even know how hot it was but it was like
super super hot
so i was like i'm just gonna like
[ __ ] deal with it i'm gonna put
sunblock on
uh it'll be fine yeah i'm florida's
planted yeah i'm florida's planet yeah
that's what i mean i was born here yeah
and they're saying
it's a hundred percent humidity here it
is pretty much all year round like i
said it's
the air yeah it's like thick yeah it's
wet this is a tropical environment air
is wet this is a tropical environment
and we have our own monsoon season and
everything yes
and it's a [ __ ] swamp this is dagobah
uh but it's a coniferous forest and
swamp it's both
and it's got bears and [ __ ]
raccoons and [ __ ] yeah there's raccoons
and
huge alligators alligators gigantic
bubble constrictors
bobcats yeah bobcats there's anacondas
and boa constrictors here that people
have let go
they live here they've escaped yeah and
they live here yeah you never know what
you're going to see
you can find you can easily find a
[ __ ]
you could be walking out there one day
and run across a [ __ ] 12 to 15 foot
long [ __ ] anaconda with the head as
big as a damn german shepherd's head
well like i said i like to tell the
story too this is like the florida story
i was driving from daytona to deland one
time
i don't remember where i was going i was
going somewhere in deland on
92 which is like the main highway
between dayton and deland
i saw a big giant alligator just running
across the road yeah
and they got 20-foot alligators and
everybody stopped and going huh
look at that i there's a run across the
right all right
and they got them 15 20 feet long it was
big it was a bit it was big
they walking they stand up they're off
the ground walking across the right
across the highway big honestly when i
was in elementary school
and this was like in the middle of like
a kind of a city or suburb
um an alligator ran across the street
like this little street that went to my
elementary school and there was like
just houses
it wasn't like there was no um
forest or anything it was just it was
suburbs it was houses and companies and
highways and whatnot so an alligator had
run across the road
that led to my elementary school and
someone had run it over
so for a long time there was like a
flattened dead alligator
yeah on the road that led to my
elementary school you got people in
there from
michigan talking about how humid it is
in michigan yeah i was in michigan
michigan gets pretty hot
um i like to actually kind of liked the
winter with the snow
you get sick of it after a while but
that was nice but no the heat
the heat in michigan is is nothing
nothing yeah it's like i compared to
florida i get that like other people
like yeah it's hot here and like it
probably
is i'm not saying it's not 100 humidity
makes a gigantic difference i think it's
like different it's a 100
humidity 100 plus degrees of heat and
i've been to like the southwest
i've been to like you know uh i've been
to colorado and i've been to like
new mexico and it's hot out there but
it's not
not the same it's not the same it's even
hotter than mississippi
all right and mississippi can get
[ __ ] hot but it's even hotter here
it's just hot hot and miserable
and [ __ ] humid people that are from
here you walk out the door and it's just
yeah like i said i was born here it's
like you walk out the door i'm like yep
i'm already tired
i'm tired i'm going back to bed it's
just you don't you just don't want to
even
deal with it people if they can will
stay indoors
for most of the summer if they can well
i always did when i was growing up you
know
we go out at night to go to clubs and we
do have to go out and run errands and
[ __ ] i mean you have to go out sometimes
but you prefer to stay in the ac if at
all possible
um but florida's got beautiful homes and
it's [ __ ] got a lot of cool [ __ ]
you do you do get all that back in the
other seasons it's very mild weather
it's
it's very enjoyable you can it's nice
here in the winter
sometimes sometimes it's still hot it's
a winter gotta say sometimes it's pretty
cold in the winter
uh but mostly just in the morning uh it
depends on how strong the winner is but
there are some winners where you could
still go to the pool
for the winner no problem yeah and
honestly it's
i remember most winners we were just
waiting
because we wanted it to be cold like
yeah like i said i was born in florida
so you would see like all the christmas
specials
it's like look at all the snow and like
look it's cold and everybody's like in
their scarves and they have like hot
chocolate
like wow i wish we could do that and
it's like and it kind of sucked that we
couldn't
so it's like every now and then like in
but it usually wasn't up to christmas
because it's usually
hot um you know hot or warm
up until january so christmas sometimes
it was cold-ish
but usually it was like 70.
so it's not real christmassy if it's
gonna get cold here it'll be
january or february so a lot of times
we'd have to wait until after christmas
which blew
because it didn't really feel all that
christmassy so sometimes january
february
get like a day or two when it went down
to like 30 degrees
and we like and that's fahrenheit so
we'd be like so excited
and we would like tell my grandma this
is when we were kids
tell my grandma please turn the
sprinklers on so it will freeze
the front yard so we can pretend that it
snowed and we can pretend like it's
winter time
and so she was like i'm gonna kill all
the grass and i'd be just like yeah but
we never get to blah blah so you know
she would do it sometimes and kill all
the grass because
you know fair play to her like r.i.p
because my grandma was awesome
so she would kill her entire yard to
freeze it
so we could get up in the morning at
like six in the morning and run out
there in our little coats and be like
wee
we like could pretend it was winter for
like an hour until it all melted
yeah and it was like it's so [ __ ] sad
it's sad
but that was like the only winter that
we ever had
that was the only winter that we ever
had yeah i wanted winter like christmas
on tv
like for so much of my childhood and i
was so bummed out
that i never got that experience and
like people from australia probably feel
me because it's probably like the same
thing down there
because that's their summer and it's
kind of like that here
gotta say because like i said if it's if
it's gonna get cold here
it's gonna be in the new year it's going
to be
january or february that's when we have
coldest temperatures
and even then honestly i've never
seen it i don't think i've ever seen it
my entire
time of living here which is almost 50
years i don't think i've ever seen it
get colder
than 28 degrees fahrenheit maybe and
that was me
that was like one night when i first
moved here in 2008 one night and there
was snow
yeah but it was back in 2008 though but
even
when we have snow i've seen snow here a
couple of times
but when you see snow here it's like
it'll be a couple of flakes and you'll
be like oh
and everybody gets super excited look
it's snowing
and then it'll stick on the ground for
like a second and then it melts no not
in 2008 it's stuck for days
no it didn't yes it is it was up in the
eustis area
well okay maybe in like the mid like
part of
nativity displays and people were
running through you know doing tours
through it and everything yeah we get
super jazz
they're all chat yeah because we never
see it
it was like normal because i had seen so
much snow but they were [ __ ]
well yeah i didn't even i didn't see
snow
until like real snow like that stayed on
the ground and like piled up and stuff
until i was 23
i went to wales uh for the first time
that year
and it snowed really bad they had like a
really bad winter and there was like a
lot of snow and i was like oh my god i
was so excited they were all like
[ __ ] pissed off because of like oh my
god
what the [ __ ] but because you know no
one could drive and was like
driving sliding all over the road and
stuff but i was in heaven
i was like i could build a snowman
awesome
because i never got to do that i never
got to do that as a kid
we didn't it didn't snow so it's like i
don't know
i feel robbed in my childhood we don't
have seasons there's no seasons
i don't know and that bums me out i feel
like i missed out on a lot of [ __ ]
i think i've mentioned this before but
when i was younger
um what no i'm just nothing when i was
younger i saw this movie
maybe one day we'll do a retrospective
on it because i really like this movie
and i think it's kind of like underrated
i think he had an 87 maybe earlier
it was called the lady in white and um
it's kind of like you know an old school
kind of ghost story
thank you victor um
for shitty movies entrance fee yeah i go
ahead and
tom shedding i'll let you in yeah there
you go and uh
so in that movie which was set in like
new england type area
yeah hold on what's it if anybody wants
to join tom
shitty movies on um
facebook go ahead and uh add yourself to
it it's it's
a fun group and it's another group we uh
post everybody posts a lot of [ __ ] there
talks about [ __ ]
oh yeah sometimes i'll post pictures
from the club and
links to [ __ ] basic [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] stripper poles and [ __ ] go
there's florida
yeah well what are you gonna do yeah
yeah but yeah so so i saw this movie and
it was like it was set in
i don't remember exactly where but it
was like up in the northeast somewhere
so it was the movie was set at halloween
and everybody was like in their little
coats
and little hats and like they were
talking about like it was halloween and
they're telling how cold it was
and when i was a little kid when i first
saw that i was like what the [ __ ] it's
not cold at halloween what the [ __ ] are
they even talking about
and then i realized that they were like
from the northeast i'm like oh maybe it
is cold out there because honestly
i grew up in florida it's like halloween
is always like hot as [ __ ]
so you always kind of had to have like a
costume that wasn't gonna like you
weren't gonna die
because you gotta walk around for hours
in this costume
and you're gonna get a heat stroke so
it's never cold on halloween ever
so i didn't i didn't understand
at first like it being cold on halloween
that like didn't compute
because i'm so used to being hot on
halloween which blows
but you know i understood later but
all right i gotta go to the bathroom so
you talk all right
i will reset the conversation we've been
on
weather for about two hours probably no
we haven't okay
so what you guys up to yeah well first
of all mike says you're not missing
anything with snow i don't think so
either
i did have some good times with snow but
whatever
but um yeah you can go ahead and uh go
on facebook and look up tom shitty
movies s-h-i-d-d-y
and um i'll let you in there we we have
fun in there too
and you guys uh got a lot of guys
showing me stuff you know
khan will show me [ __ ] [ __ ] movies
movie posters and
just talk about stuff and um
some of the clubs we go to post [ __ ]
crazy videos that they took in the clubs
and i'll share them into the group
a couple days ago i shared one that had
like five
there's over mannequins my friends my
friend tom's club
over at mannequins had these like five
basic [ __ ]
uh just regular florida girls they
weren't goth or anything
and they're trying to get up on the
stripper pole and [ __ ] sling around
trying to look sexy as possible
it wasn't really working it was [ __ ]
funny but uh
i just put that [ __ ] up there and said
basic and [ __ ]
dj's wife started just started laughing
underneath there
see what's going on here
all right dj says uh had to explain to
you that the costumes on new year's eve
um used to uh be a thing
after the terror train review it
happened in training places as well i'm
not really sure what that's in
reference to jen you might understand
terry's asking me to do a retelling of
the mammoth mountain culture guys
am i going to do it no man right now
sure you guys want me to talk about
mammoth well yeah
he's laying out in the living room yeah
like she's all stretched out and i came
out of the bathroom and she just like
turned her little head upside down
looked at me going
yeah look look at me yeah like a monster
yeah she's so cute
i mean you should you you could give
like an abbreviated
for people that haven't read the book so
sick of telling that one
are you really kind of i mean don't feel
like you have that in fact
zach was asking me about that today hey
man well see like people are interested
do you think the volcano had
anything to do with them yeah he said he
was mad because you didn't like
uh no dj maniac says i had to explain to
you that costumes on new year's eve used
to be a thing
after the terror train review it
happened in trading places as well yeah
he sent me a review about that and i had
totally forgotten about that scene of
trading places
and i was like another generation i
guess maybe it was because i don't ever
remember
like i said the only thing i remember
like new year's eve people were like
stupid hats and like
have horns and stuff but i don't
remember anybody like doing like a
full-on costume like masquerade [ __ ] i
thought it was more like halloween
what's up poop cookie just throws the
door open yeah she's like
yeah don't close the door um
the whole mammoth thing was a [ __ ]
weird experience
um
my aunt lois and red my aunt lois and
uncle red
and my um cousin wesley
all came with me at a place called math
mountain and it was
this long story how my mom worked for an
oil company called conoco
she was the secretary down there and her
i guess she was dating her boss or
something like that i think she was oh
[ __ ] i don't think you told me that
yeah she ended up she ended up living
with him it was russ
and i think i think it was her boss or
or she knew him he was one of the
one of the executives and
uh he had he had the ability to get
access to like [ __ ] company perks and
one of the things was is kind of like a
the ability to stay at the company um
[ __ ] lodge they they had
they um had a ski lodge
well not really ski lodge there was a
ski resort called chateau de montage
okay i don't mention it that in the in
the book
just on the show we changed the names of
some people
and some like yeah we didn't want to get
sued it's a bunch of con
bunch of condos up there in the
mountains
near a ski resort and the company owned
one of them
there's nothing special about that place
don't be looking that place up and
[ __ ] [ __ ] with them the people
that would work there now would know
nothing about
what this story they wouldn't know
anything well this was a long time ago
it's been like re
yeah and i think they may have changed
the numbers
i remember what number it was and i
think they might have changed the
numbers on them when i was looking at
through google earth i think they might
have renumbered maybe they tore one of
them down they
changed changed the numbers i'm not sure
but um my mom's boyfriend was able to
get that thing for the
hot for the christmas weekend
and for the christmas vacation but my
mom and
and her boyfriend didn't want to go so
my mom offered it
to my lois and she goes yo yeah i'll go
and i [ __ ] said yeah i want to go too
i want to go with him
yeah yeah yeah i liked hanging out with
my lois
uncle red and [ __ ] my my cousin
wesley more than i liked hanging out
because he was the same age as you yeah
yeah you know like hanging out with mom
and [ __ ] i was like [ __ ] 13 12 13.
[ __ ] that i'm gonna go christmas up
there [ __ ] uncle red uncle red was
[ __ ] cool man
and we'd do all kinds of [ __ ] he'd
[ __ ] eat them damn little [ __ ]
little zingers and [ __ ] and those little
[ __ ] what flavor
the zingers are zingers flavor no no
wait no there was there were the [ __ ]
red ones with the [ __ ] coconut
on them and the jelly and what they
don't know what they called that [ __ ] i
see i like the leather they were little
hostess ones and they were
[ __ ] red i didn't like those though i
like the lemon ones he used to also get
them down
we always end up talking about snack
cake something yeah i used to get those
[ __ ] lemon drop
sunshine lemon drop cookies and then we
used to get what was that other thing
that used to get pecan sandies we used
to get the
pecan sandwich oh i love those yeah i
love pecan sandies i think they still
make those that's the keebler right
yeah yeah yeah those are good so um
and and so we go up to and i [ __ ]
tell you man that's just gonna blow your
mind
all right if you haven't heard it yeah
michael red was young he was in his 20s
at that time
he didn't really bend anywhere this was
like a [ __ ] big deal to him to go he
could play guitar this dude was [ __ ]
badass guitarist
he was in all these country western and
rock bands in california during that
time he ended up being a music teacher
he died about a year ago out of a heart
attack
so he wanted to go up there with my aunt
lois and he's going to have a good time
yeah i've never been to the mountains
oh yeah that's [ __ ] cool so yeah he
offered me some free [ __ ] like yeah
and he's like and red's like [ __ ] you
know what i'm gonna do
he's just look at what i got man that's
[ __ ] tequila he had the tequila
yeah he had tequila because we're gonna
make some sunrises we'll take a
continuous sunrise we get up there let's
go
yeah they're gonna give them like 13
year olds there right oh back in
california
california early 80s hell yeah yeah you
didn't tell me oh yeah no no
there was no stigma of that just
although like i said when i was a kid
people would be like hey have some beer
kid
yeah yeah that's a modern [ __ ]
concept
that a little kid could not drink
alcohol they weren't allowed to buy
alcohol and go into a bar but your
parents are just kind of like here shut
up yeah
under parent supervision or under the
supervision of your family
that they could give you some alcohol as
long as you stayed inside the house
you guys like you're not going to get
too rough yeah now you couldn't give the
neighbors kids alcohol not without
[ __ ]
parents permission but back they were
talking early 80s it was not an issue
back then and i was going oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's drink some of that when
we get down there
we never did drink any of that though
because i was going to say you didn't
really matter no i never did
i kind of feel like i think maybe we we
took a few sips of it
that was about it [ __ ] because the
mood changed once we got up there
so we packed up all our [ __ ] now
i'm [ __ ] just telling the whole
[ __ ] story from day one
packed up all our [ __ ] we were driving
up there
and i was trying to have a good time
but i just had this weird feeling coming
over me i was in the back seat they were
driving a company car up there
we were supposed to leave the car there
to come back on the bus because the
company wanted us to deliver that car to
the
to to the uh uh
to the condo and leave it there yeah
because someone else was supposed to
come somebody else is supposed to come
get it it's supposed to be something
that the company would
have up there you know so
we're on our way there
and i started to get creeped out we were
driving on these roads it was snowing
and on the other side i was looking up
to the left and the left was like a
cliff
on the mountains you know and my uncle
red is kind of stressing out
driving this thing in this i would be
slow i don't like that
it's snowing there's a [ __ ] pretty
much a sheer cliff on the other side and
i could tell he was [ __ ]
and i was [ __ ] in the back and lois
was sitting up front with him i was in
the back with wesley
and i just got this weird feeling that i
was being watched and then i started to
have this
kind of like um
started having this feelings of dread
like i was going somewhere bad
and i started to think of the overlook
hotel because i saw that
that that [ __ ] kubrick movie yeah the
shining
because this was the shining came out in
1980 this was in 82 christmas of 80s
yeah
and but it was during the time when they
were playing
the shining on on um
hbo all the time is that hbo or or
yeah cause i'm pretty sure i saw it then
and it like
scared me and i was like because i'm
pretty sure i saw it when i was about
i'm
going up to some place it's kind of like
a hotel and there's these mountains and
[ __ ] you know what i mean what if
this place is [ __ ] haunted
i'm starting to think that you know you
did it
and i felt this [ __ ] fear kind of
building up into me and then
boom the [ __ ]
the hood flew open and blocked the
[ __ ] view
red's view and he [ __ ] put the brakes
on gently to stop
and my [ __ ] heart was pounding
[ __ ] lois is looking at me and he
he's looking around like what the [ __ ]
was that
he gets out and looks at the [ __ ]
hood and shuts it and try and he comes
back in the lowest is like what what it
was he goes i couldn't see anything
wrong with it
that's some weird [ __ ] you did that
because you know how they have the damn
latch where it opens and then it's
there's a safety thing so it can't open
up any further
he couldn't see what the problem was man
the [ __ ] hood on my car is like
[ __ ] really hard
yeah you have to like pop the [ __ ] from
inside and then you have to like find it
yeah under the thing and then even then
you're kind of like where the [ __ ] is
it's like in a weird place and it's like
really hard to pop open
so that happened and it didn't make me
feel much better
um so i drive up there and it starts
getting kind of creepier and creepier to
me as we get
closer we were that happened we were
maybe about a half hour away from it i
think
didn't lois say we're about a half hour
away i can't remember but i think she
said something like that
they were older than i was so that so
you know of course their memories a
little bit
well that's why like i interviewed them
for the book right yeah in case anybody
didn't know
so when we get there it doesn't look
anything like the overlook hotel it's
just a bunch of
a bunch of um what do you call it just
like condos
they're brown wood on the outside and
they got a sloped tops it looked like a
regular condo you'd see from the late
70s like something out of a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cronenberg movie or something
you know like something out of the brood
although you hadn't seen that i hadn't
seen that yet that's what it looked like
everything kind of looked like that it
did yeah so
just just so people understand so they
went up to the front office and they got
everything for it and they we find the
one
the fight we because we had to get the
key i think or they had to check in or
something
they remember they went to the front
office
and um
we go there parked the car
and they opened the door to walk in and
when they opened the door
lois went in first and then red went in
the lowest one oh that's
weird it's weird in here and [ __ ] as
i stepped in i
felt it it felt like some kind of high
pressure
zone was in there
like just some kind of weird stillness
like something was watching you and that
was the only way only thing
that's the only way i could really
explain it now i had
a bag in my hand it was a blue vinyl
travel bag that had
two straps on top of it and had a zipper
that went through
and it was zip closed and it had
you know underwear and socks and clothes
and [ __ ] like that in it
when i went in the front door the first
door on the right was the first room and
there was another room and i could see
another room at the end and then there
was a staircase that went up to the top
room
and lois said okay well choose your room
and the first i chose the first room on
the right when you went through the
[ __ ] door
i said i'll take this one and i threw
the
through my travel bag on the bed
and they walked straight kept walking
down the hallway
and wesley chose the bedroom next to it
during that time i was heading back out
to the car because i had a little
suitcase to pick up
i get that suitcase come back inside
and go into that room where i threw the
the uh
the travel bag on the bed and saw
movement and saw a [ __ ]
rolled up pair of socks [ __ ] move it
didn't come to a halt as soon as i
looked at it
and the the bag was on its side and it
was open
and those pair of socks was like three
feet away down the down of the foot of
the bed
and i was like no no no no
couldn't be i didn't open that i said
maybe i did open that and it fell over
and the socks rolled out that was
my that's how i explained well yeah
that's what that's what you would think
but i had a weird feeling when that
happened
so i took all that [ __ ] and put it in
drawers
day went on kind of normally
um
we went out see what i'm trying to
remember what happened next
it must have been kind of late in the
day or something
i remember that later on that night
i was laying in bed and i could have
swore i heard something dragging across
the carpet at the foot of the bed
it sounded like something big like the
dresser
but i was afraid to open my eyes at it
i've looked open my eyes and looked it
was dark in there and i didn't see
anything
and then i heard the telephone receiver
in the [ __ ]
on the right on the right near on the
right of the bed up near the front was a
nightstand there was two of them on
either side of the bed on this side was
a nightstand and the door out
on this side was a nightstand with a
phone on it in the corner of the room
i heard something moving at the foot i
heard that first
and i looked i didn't see anything and
as i was looking that direction
i heard the receiver the telephone pick
up and then drop
on the [ __ ] phone and i was scared to
look
i don't i believe it
so i looked and didn't see anything and
i was so scared man that i [ __ ]
willed myself to fall asleep and as i
was as i was willing myself to fall
asleep
i heard a couple of empty coat hangers
in the closet [ __ ] jingled together
remember those old metal coat hangers i
heard him go
like a wind blew through there but it
was closed
yeah you woke up the next day i was kind
of [ __ ]
trying to shake it off i was pretty you
know wigged out about it
and uh we all went down to the ski
slopes
and it was kind of [ __ ] with me in
the back of my mind
and while i was there i said i kept
asking red
if he'd ever been in a haunted house and
he said yeah i was
i think we were in a place we were
playing one time playing uh we were
rehearsing for a gig and heard something
moving in the walls we thought maybe it
was a ghost because that might have just
been rats
well i asked him a couple times about
haunted houses and ghosts
and he's like why are you asking me this
i said oh nothing
you think that place is haunted and i
said yeah i think it is
it says why do you think that and i told
him what happened
and he goes let's leave lois here don't
tell her don't tell her that happened
let's leave her here because she was
skiing let's go back over there and
[ __ ]
check that place out i was like all
right
so we go back to the lot to the lodge to
the condo
and when we get there
we found towels little hand towels
folded up and put on the back of some of
the
some of the doorknobs and we found
little hand towels folded up and soap
little travel subs at the foot of the
beds
you know what i mean like you know where
you were at the base of the bed
where you would sit and red's like what
is this
is this is this some kind of
well we're looking at it and we're like
is this some kind of room service that
did this
i don't know well down on the down
bottom floor at the very end of the at
the very end the room at the very end of
the hallway
there was a room that had bunk beds and
a drafting table and a little stool that
had it back on it was a drafting table
where a person could
do drafting i guess it part of being a
company house or whatever i don't know
that's just what they had in there
and it had the
on the back of that stool it had a
folded up hand towel
along the back of it like right here you
know yeah sitting there
and red pointed at that and he's going
what is this
who does that what kind of room service
does it yeah that seems like a weird
place to put a hand
i don't know so it was pulled out about
a foot
he pushed it in like that you know
i i think he pushed it in and then we
went back and got lois
i think that's how that went
we told lois about it and she goes
really
later on we saw that we we looked at
that stool again and it had moved
a little bit and i said red you remember
you pushed this in and he goes yeah yeah
i did push that
in because it was pulled back out again
and lois go man this is really weird so
red pushed that chair back in and we
were getting ready to walk out of that
room
and red goes wait hold on he was just
shutting the door
he was let's memorize it i said yeah
yeah he opened the door and that chair
was
pulled back out and
i said look at that well no no no that's
not how that happened it was pulled back
we came back and it was pulled out it
was
about eight inches because because he
said i pushed that back in yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and you're like yeah we pushed it back
in and left
and then when we came back in we noticed
that the lamp was gone and the lamp was
in the closet with the [ __ ]
with the power cable going across the
floor pointed to where it was plugged in
and i [ __ ] screamed and ran
there was no time for anybody in there
yeah so pick that lamp up
what you told me happened was like only
you were looking at the rim
yeah that's right because red was saying
look like i pushed that chair in and now
it's pulled out again
like we just went back to get you guys
from the slopes
right and now like the chair is [ __ ]
up right um
and look there's all these hand towels
like laid around yeah
and then like i think lois said
something because i talked to her as
well
yeah like on the phone like i
interviewed her extensively about the
[ __ ]
and she said yeah i commented about how
ugly the lamp was
that it was like on the table next to
the bed yeah i have a this is just the
very first thing that happened
yeah a lot of [ __ ] happened so much [ __ ]
happened that i couldn't remember it all
and
red had to remind me of some of the [ __ ]
that happened
well that's why i'm glad that i mean
like i said he's passed away now but
it's like it's really good
like what had happened with the matchbox
cars and everything
yeah you had forgotten about i've
forgotten all about the matchbox car so
i got to i
interviewed him so i interviewed like
them and him like separately
yeah because the first thing the first
time that he told me about this story
um i was like i believed it but i was
like still pretty skeptical
yeah so he said we'll call
lois and red yeah and so i talked to
lois and red like separately from him
yeah like in another room like he wasn't
listening i had
talked to him in years so i talked to
them like extensively and they told me
pretty much
the same story that you told me and
there were certain things i forgot about
i kind of forgot about the knife
yeah did i forget about the knife or did
i remember the night there were certain
elements well that happened later
much later that wasn't a mammoth see it
didn't just happen there it happened to
also lois house my house
and it's happened in here but it's
nowhere near as good it used to be
much stronger yeah we've had [ __ ] happen
in here too it's not scary
it's just oh it was back in those days
yeah i could see that
i mean i wasn't scared by it that's what
i meant the weirdest thing that i saw is
i saw [ __ ]
was walking this is in mammoth there was
two things that were [ __ ]
pretty astounding that i saw lois and
them
saw stuff that was even weirder but i
wasn't in the room when it happened
they saw the pillows [ __ ] being
thrown and [ __ ] i was walking down a
hallway and [ __ ] saw
red look into a room and go and gasp and
i ran up there to see what it was he's
looking at
and he looks looking at a rocking chair
with a whole bunch of folded up towels
sitting on it
and they were it was rocking like that
fast
pretty fast like a person shaking it on
the back
and i just [ __ ] man whoa whoa whoa
and then
as soon as i was kind of like taking it
in i saw like a blurry spot
on the back of it like right here you
know like up here yeah
i saw some kind of blurry clear spot go
like it was jumped off of it and then
got smaller or it went away
like something that was holding it and
then let go it was [ __ ] weird man
that one was pretty weird another one
was like lois's apartment this is like a
couple days later after we left
lois was had a plate of cheese and
crackers and she was cutting the cheese
with a knife
and put it on crackers and i was
watching television
and she got up but she got up and put
that thing
in the kitchen and when she sat back
down and
rested my head back on the other couch
like that and something touched my head
my hair and i looked back like that and
it was that same knife she just put away
and i said lois it's back the knife and
she took it she's going my god that's so
weird
we were kind of getting used to it at
that point in a weird way yeah because
this was you've been a week at mammoth
and like yeah
and then she put the knife back in the
kitchen and walked back into the room
with us and at that time red was walking
in says what happened with the knife
and a [ __ ] flash of light that knife
came flying through the air
went right in front of me hit the hit
went right to the sliding glass doors
stopped
dead and then boom fell down at my feet
and didn't bounce
boom like that that [ __ ] piece of
that knife and i was
what was a kitchen knife like one of you
that was the
that was the weirdest thing that i saw
my i jumped out of my [ __ ] skin
and red was just like he just went
[ __ ] pale
that was that was that was [ __ ] weird
it didn't hit the glass it stopped right
before it hit that [ __ ] glass
and bounced away from it like whatever
had it still had a hold of it
and then it just sucked it into the
ground with my feet
bow and it man that was [ __ ] weird
well like i said if you guys don't know
we had this because like i said i'm like
i'm skeptical like paranormal stuff
um but he told me the story
wrote the book about it and then while
we were talking about
because we were kind of like talking
about this a lot we were talking about
we were talking to lois i'm right on the
phone all the time so we were like kind
of we were talking to steve mara all the
time we were talking about like
poltergeist [ __ ] like pretty much 24 7.
so then uh phenomena
started occurring in this house
the first time that it happened um
me and you and demetri and jen
were here your mom was here
and we were sitting around in the living
room
and we were trying to watch
mad max fury road i remember that
because we were like gonna because we
had seen it many
many times but to be true jenna not seen
it they wanted to see it
so we were gonna like at that time you
could just get it on pay-per-view
uh now we have on blu-ray but so we were
trying to get on pay-per-view and it
wasn't uh working we were having all
kind of like
issues so we had to like call
you know the whatever was it directv or
whoever it was yeah so we were like
calling them like trying to get that
[ __ ] and like tom's getting really
frustrated
and because he's like he really wanted
he was very excited to like show
demetrius movie
so he was like really mad about it and
so we're sitting there like waiting
for customer service or whatever and
we're sitting around
me and him are on this couch dimitri and
jenner on this couch
and all of a sudden the remote control
picked itself up off the
coffee table and flew about
two or three feet i would say and then
fell to the ground but didn't bounce
it just made a funny noise yeah it made
well it made a noise it was like much
louder than what you would think a
little plastic
piece of nothing would make it went like
it picked itself up it went shoot and
then it went
yeah bam it went like that but it stuck
and it's funny because i didn't see it i
was there but they were the ones that
saw it i
saw it i didn't see it pick up but i saw
it when it was in mid-air
yeah because i was sitting like right in
front of it but it was a little bit
below my eye line
yeah but i saw it when it would because
i was like what the [ __ ] i thought
at first the first thing i thought was
that i had kicked the table
without realizing it yeah um but it
couldn't it was a glass table
i don't think i did though no because we
there were
two or three other remotes on that table
before that in the way
and they didn't move yeah and they
didn't move it was just that one and it
seemed to very deliberately
pick itself up off the table and fly and
then when it hit
the ground it just went yeah
and it made like a like a bam it made
like a weird
yeah like a much louder note than it
would make when it
does it's not normal movement because
like i said it's a plastic remote
control
we did it like after that happened and
dimitri and jen like looked at me like
what the [ __ ] did you just see that i'm
like did you
just just see that because what the [ __ ]
so then we were like trying to like pick
it up and drop it like what kind of
noise does that make and it's just like
it just goes crazy
like a little like clattery noise and
that wasn't the noise yeah you forgot
there's more to that well i know that
happened i stood up
and felt that [ __ ] weird feeling and
looked down at my feet and there was a
stack of coins
yeah and that stack of coins came from a
bedroom it was in between my feet
that was weird that was weird then the
day before it had pulled the molding off
of the [ __ ]
did you do that i thought did that do
that i thought that did that after
no i did it before but i wasn't home for
that i was at work
pulled that up pumpkin fell and hit the
ground
it was weird i was like what happened
did the moisture warp it and
no it pulled the pull it out well it
pulled the nails out
by the nails yeah it pulled the nails
out also it just uh
it can come and go depending on whatever
your mental state is
if you think about it too much it'll but
you can't really control it it's
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis but
like i said to me i don't
know it's not scary to me because i know
that it's you doing it
you got scared though you thought
something was watching you when was that
you went to that bathroom she said you
said you felt something [ __ ] watching
you over the shoulder
and then it rang the doorbell in the
middle of the night twice
like i said i'm pretty sure i wasn't
that scared because i
figured it was like your [ __ ] i figured
it was yours open the garage door
well yeah it rang the doorbell at four
in the morning
it was a couple days later a couple days
later the doorbell rang at four in the
morning
yeah and i was awake it rang twice
yeah well that was the thing um i heard
it rang
and i was awake but i was kind of like
okay
i'm going to uh chalk that up to me
just imagining that or dreaming it or
whatever um so i didn't wake you up but
then it
did it again like the doorbell rang
again
and it was four in the morning and i was
wide awake
so i'm like okay at this point i'm
waking you up
because that's weird yeah uh so and i'm
like and
i'm not going to the door [ __ ] that so i
woke you up at that point so
like i said that was it had already
happened and i was pretty sure that i
heard it
it wasn't like oh it was because i was
awake it wasn't like oh i just it woke
me up i was already awake
see a lot of people don't like the story
i got grandparents in there goofing on
me
it's uh it wasn't a ghost we thought it
was a ghost at the time we used to call
it a ghost but
no we did some we
we tried to test it we did a bunch of
stuff try to get it to react and just
over time i realized that it was
what parapsychologists called rspk which
is recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
it's it's something that the
subconscious mind can do under certain
circumstances there's a doctor there's a
doctor and a [ __ ]
um his name is um stuart hameroff
and then a nobel peace prize winning um
physicist his name is uh what's that
fucker's name
roger penrose yeah and um
they believe in something called quantum
consciousness
now these are they're pretty pembros is
a huge name a lot of people
can't are afraid to attack him on it
but your consciousness and in your mind
is not just simply computation like in a
computer
there's some kind of quantum computation
going on
quantum computing is [ __ ] weird very
weird
and it's going to involve a bunch of
quantum physics
which would allow for things that the
average person might consider
mind over matter but that's not exactly
what it is it's more kind of like the
mind influencing
the reality of certain kinds of physics
having a good example would be like
schrodinger's cat and the collapse of
the of wave form
is what they call it where
how long or how long is time
that's another thing is like
how long is right now the
you know how long the past is and you
kind of know how long the duration of
the future is
but if you were to freeze right now
would right now be the same everywhere
it would only be what was right now a
localized construct
there doesn't seem to be a present how
long is a present
it seems to be infinitesimally small and
if it's infinitesimally small there's
not a big difference between past and
present
that it's all like an illusion
um well the president is a very
ephemeral god
yeah the the present or the right now
is not real
if it's infinitesimally small it's the
same as saying it doesn't exist
well that's like in the past like right
you said that that's right in the past
now
right well
time doesn't exist separate from space
it's space time
time and space are the same thing so
what that means is that same effect is
happening in
space too and distance so you start
[ __ ] around with concepts like that
things that are real or not really real
they're only real if you see it that
kind of [ __ ]
and which is it's mind-boggling stuff
that's not supposed to be true but it
might be
well our brains didn't really evolve to
uh kind of
uh comprehend that stuff right so it
could be that your mental state might
actually affect matter
which that's that's weird now
aliens might know about this they might
use effort before
propulsion and they might understand how
to [ __ ]
trick things and trick reality to cheat
you know uh to move faster than possible
or to [ __ ] teleport because
some of the stuff that i saw [ __ ]
amounted to teleportation
objects appearing out of nowhere so
yeah i've seen it
so it means we don't have a very good
grasp of physics
is it supernatural no i don't think it's
supernatural i wouldn't call it that
it's just paranormal
i just think it's [ __ ] we don't
understand yeah yeah this [ __ ] we don't
understand it i don't i don't think it's
ghosts i don't think it's it
well like i said even when it happened
in the house yeah
the first thing i did you can attest to
this
weird [ __ ] happen like the the remote
control just randomly went flying across
the room and did like the weird [ __ ]
that it did
the first thing i did was turn to him
inside and i said did you do that
yeah did you do that that was the first
thing i thought well it looks like a lot
of people have been dropped off
actually being boring probably
might be tough [ __ ] might be time [ __ ]
might be time to shut the show down it's
early we need to [ __ ] get a drink
[ __ ] get something to eat yeah eating
watch [ __ ]
we've probably been doing the show for
three maybe three four hours so
three hours and 33 minutes yeah it's
time to shut it down
you think yeah it didn't really seem
like that long no it went by fast
it's weird because i kind of like felt
like we didn't really have any
[ __ ] to talk about but we always went by
fast we always find some [ __ ]
we wore them out tila didn't show up a
lot of our regulars uh she said that she
was uh traveling for work it wouldn't be
able to come by
like she sent me a thing earlier okay so
that's why
all right um but yeah we had a troll
that was exciting that's funny i mean
not really but yeah that's never
exciting y'all aren't exciting
but um good try though yep valiant
effort
yeah not really but um victor said is
that work he's in and out
and esther didn't show either terry said
yeah oh yeah esther's on here although i
got a message
i got a couple messages from her earlier
on patreon
because she was telling me about re
aster
uh who did midsummer and hereditary
yeah has a new movie that's coming out
but i don't know
when exactly it's coming out i think
it's called disappointments boulevard
something like that
i don't know if it's a horror movie but
we'll see
i mean i kind of feel like he should
only be allowed to make horror movies
because that's kind of seems like his
wheelhouse but we'll see all right
before we check off another thing that i
wanted to mention
about quantum computation and everything
there's another guy who looked into it
he he was a physicist and he was
actually looking into
poltergeist what he considered to be
good poltergeist cases
and he thought that guys were looking at
this for a long time this isn't
new he thought that possibly it might
have had something to do
with altered states of consciousness
having to do with the fight or flight
response
that could it and and that kind of makes
sense because when it first happened i
was getting scared
about going to a haunted house and i was
already in kind of a stressful
environment so it was probably very much
linked to
it's almost kind of like you generated
it because when you were going up there
you were already like priming yourself
and it's non-local so it had been
primed up in a location we hadn't been
to yet
but that didn't matter because you're
dealing with something that's happening
outside of space
normal space time so it knew where we
would go in the future
because it knew what the future was
because it's outside space time
it was a singular yeah i mean honestly i
kind of feel like
i don't think there's anything
supernatural about it as in
people's consciousness consciousness
survives after death or anything but
it's like i do kind of feel like
not in the way that people that believe
in ghosts
uh you know kind of posit but i do kind
of feel like people's brains
have some like weird properties
that maybe we don't know about yeah well
that's where there's things about you
know dreaming true and predominations
and that's what i'm saying possibly
talking to the dead that's why i don't
want to call it supernatural because i
don't think it's supernatural in the
sense of being outside of nature because
i don't
think there's any such thing right uh as
being outside of nature
uh if we've discovered something and we
kind of see
this is a phenomenon that happens and we
kind of know how it works or maybe what
the mechanism is
garcia says poltergeist is teenage horny
energy affecting the environment
i think it might be that too i think it
might be it's stronger when you're young
going through puberty definitely i think
it might be
and that's not just me saying that
one of the older cases was 1700s
tokugawa japan
and they noticed that there was a young
servant girl and pots and pans would
jump around and be thrown and they know
that she didn't touch it
they called in a samurai who was a
scholar and investigator
and he tried to figure out what was
happening around this little girl it
basically did
two things around this young teenage
girl
it made pots and pans jump and dance or
be thrown and it ripped
silk sheets and it could do it
poltergeists are super into like ripping
fabric particularly in triangular
patterns
that's something that i've seen a lot
and evidently it did it
in a kind of a mindless fashion over and
over again very
repetitive and the samurai came up with
a good idea
he says well she's going through puberty
this is an imbalance of chi
energy and the extra chi energy is
coming off into this
force that's doing she's just throwing
it off yeah and that's like and i think
which in a way that sounds like the most
possible something like that
so there's an imbalance of the chi
energy not supernatural
boiling all over yeah boiling over and
it's got to do something
and you know so that's how he
interpreted it and he's probably
close some people have like super
puberty apparently
and it's like their body can't contain
all of the
well he also mentioned some stuff about
her family life and stuff and that she
was kind of unhappy working in that
working in the house he thought the
frustration and the other things in it
because she couldn't which that was a
very sophisticated way
of analyzing it i don't remember the
guy's name but that was just one of the
older cases that
i that i heard about if that actually
happened if that's not a fake report
about an old case
yeah because that's something that
happens too yeah you gotta watch that
but it was supposed to be an early one
from tokugawa japan
like i said that kind of totally makes
sense because i mean certain people
if they have certain uh emotional issues
or they have certain like
family dynamics or family situations um
you know they're gonna have like we have
all these emotions
i can deal with this many emotions and
then it goes like extra bodily
i guess if you wanna like say that it's
almost like that
yeah so i can almost kind of buy that
and like i said i'm
pretty skeptical but that sounds more
plausible to me than
than ghosts or demons then oh people's
consciousness
survives after death which to me i don't
see a mechanism for that
but quantum computation quantum
quantum entanglement of the mind i had
that outer body experience in the near
death experience i think it does
now are you you not for long you become
somebody it's something else
but let's go ahead and end the show
we've got the show's been going on too
long yeah i'm kind of hungry yeah i'm
tired all right so thank you everybody
for dropping by thanks for super chats
we'll be back on friday night we're
going to be talking about the [ __ ]
raelians man
yeah that's going to get you which like
i said it's kind of a cult
but the more i read about them the more
i'm like i don't know if i want to call
them a call because they seem kind of
cool
so laughs i mean it is but it's like
not not in the worst ways okay let's put
it like that
yeah there's some like kind of religious
sects that are i don't agree with
everything they say but
in some ways i'm just like whatever just
let them do let them do their thing they
don't hurt anybody
so it's that kind of thing so uh you
know i can't put any wigs on tonight but
i will
i will i was gonna say you didn't even
do anything one is you know
you haven't done your mozart wig in a
long time or you're thomas jeff or
something like it
it's gotta come over me man it's got
it's got to be from the heart i can't
[ __ ] just artificially do that [ __ ]
okay yeah
you just wore the same hat all night
yeah
yeah yes boring night oh i feel
like go ahead man shut up no i'm hungry
i'm just gonna like compound it yeah you
failed
i know no i'm just kidding yeah really
all right so yeah so hopefully everybody
had a good time this evening
we will see you guys friday night we're
going to talk about the raelians and
it'll be super fun
thanks everybody for dropping by thanks
for your super chats and we'll see you
guys on friday night
see you later bye